So I was thinking the other day
about
numbers,
you know,
there are mathematicians who think
that there isn't anything more real,
the numbers,
and that's an interesting proposition.
I mean it's obviously the case that
once you invent or discover numbers that
that confers on you a tremendous power
and who knows the limits of that power
and
the claim that numbers are more real than
anything else is predicated in part on
the fact that when you discover them or
invent them and start to utilize them,
that your ability to operate
in the world expands immensely.
And so that's one of the ways of judging
whether or not something is real is
whether or not when you use it,
that facilitates your means
of operating in the world.
Interestingly,
numbers are abstractions.
And so that raises
another question which is,
well,
what's more real?
The thing that's being abstracted from
or the abstractions and again that's not
obvious and maybe the question
of more real isn't Germane.
Maybe it's a question of equal reality,
but it's not obvious that abstractions
aren't real and you can make a strong
case that there are more
real than anything else,
and so then you might ask yourself,
well then what are the
most real abstractions?
And so that's what I'm going
to start to talk about tonight.
I'm going to talk about it in
relationship to as many rules as I can
layout simultaneously.
I'll go through the rules first.
So rule one is stand up straight
with your shoulders back,
and rule two is treat yourself like
you're someone responsible for helping a
number three,
which is very tightly
associated with number two.
There are sort of variations on a theme
is make friends with those people who
want the best for you.
And by the way,
these last two rules aren't injunctions
designed to make your life easier.
They're actually injunctions designed
to make your life more difficult.
Character Guard said at one
point that his role in life,
given that everything was proceeding to
become easier and easier in all possible
ways,
that there would come a time when
people would cry out for difficulty.
And so that's partly how he
envisioned role in the world,
interestingly enough,
as a universal benefactor of mankind who
would strive to do nothing other than
to make life more difficult for everyone.
Right?
And so rule two and three are like that
because treat yourself as if you're
someone responsible for helping isn't
the same as be nice to yourself.
It's not that.
And to associate with people who want
the best for you means that they get to
demand the best from you.
And that's also not an easy thing.
Rule four is compare yourself to who you
were yesterday and not to who someone
else is today.
And that's an injunction about envy,
right?
It's easy.
You need people who need things that
are above you because you need to do
something worthwhile with your life.
You need something to a map,
but one of the consequences of that is
that you can become envious of people
that you believe have attained more
in a deserved or undeserved manner,
and that can make you better.
And so it's much better to
compare yourself to yourself
and to use yourself as
the target for improvement.
And comparison rule five is don't let
your children do anything that makes you
dislike them,
and the rule of thumb there
is if you dislike them,
then other people will,
and it's a bad idea to allow your
children to act in a way that makes other
children disliked them
or adults disliked them,
given that they're going to have to deal
with children and they're going to have
to deal with adults.
So your primary responsibility as a
parent is to help your child learn how to
behave so that the social world opens
up its arms to them and welcomes them at
every level and you've done your job.
If you can manage that,
and it's not a simple thing to do.
Rule six is put your house in perfect
order before you criticize the world,
and that's not take no action for
others until you have your act together.
That isn't what the rule means.
It means that bind your ambition with
humility and work on what's right in front
of you that you will suffer
for if you get wrong,
before you engage in the large scale
transformation of other people.
Rule seven is do what is meaningful
and not what is expedient,
and I would say in some
sense in some sense,
that's the core ethos of the book,
not exactly because rule eight,
which is tell the truth or at least don't
lie as a necessary conjunction to that
are unnecessary additional element
because I don't think that you can pursue
what is meaningful
without telling the truth,
and the reason for that is if you don't
tell the truth or let's say if you lie,
which is an easier way to think about it,
you corrupt the mechanisms,
the instinctual mechanisms that that that
manifest as meaning and then you can't
trust them and that's a very bad idea.
So the fundamental reason to not
lie is because you corrupt your own
perceptions.
If you lie and when you
corrupt your own perceptions,
then you can't rely on yourself
and if you can't rely on yourself,
then well good luck to you because what
are you going to rely on in the absence
of your own judgment?
Your you've got nothing.
If you,
if you lose that rule,
rule eight a is,
as I said,
tell the truth or don't,
or at least don't lie.
Rule nine,
assume that the person that you're
listening to know something you don't,
and that's not so much a mark
of respect for the person,
although it is that it's a
mark of recognition of your
own unbearable ignorance.
You know,
one of the things you have to do in
life is decide whether you're more.
You have to make friends more with.
Let me see.
Let me,
let me rephrase that properly.
You have to decide what's more important,
what you know or what you don't know.
First of all,
there's a lot of what you don't know,
and so if you make friends with that,
if you decide that's important,
then well,
that's a good thing because you're going
to be surrounded by what you don't know
your entire life.
And so if you're appreciative of that,
then that's going to make
things go better for you.
But,
but the other element of that is,
well,
why should you be appreciative
of what you don't know?
And the answer to that is,
well,
you shouldn't if you're life is absolutely
perfect in every way you have exactly
what you needed and want.
You've put everything in order around
you then what you know is sufficient.
But if you believe that things could
still be put right around you in your own
personal life and with regard
to the effect that you have,
another people,
then obviously what you don't yet know,
it was more important than what you do
know and you should be paying attention
to find out what you don't
know at every possible moment.
And if you're fortunate,
when you have a conversation with someone
and you're actually interested in what
they say,
then even if they're not
very good at communicating,
even if they're awkward or even if
they display a certain amount of enmity
towards you,
there's always the possibility that
they might tell you something you don't
know.
In which case you can walk away from the
conversation less ignorant and corrupt
than you were when you
started the conversation.
And if your life isn't everything
that you would like it to be,
than being slightly less ignorant
and corrupt is probably a good thing,
and so the rule 10 years be precise
in your speech and that's that's an
observation I would say that that's a
variant of a new testament in junction
which is or maybe a description of the
nature of the world which is knock and
the door will open and ask and you will
receive which a very strange theory
let's say,
but which I would say is far more in
accordance with what we know about the
psychology of perception,
let's say,
than you might imagine
because it is the case that
you don't get what you don't aim at.
You might get what you do a mat and
your aim might get better as you aim as
well,
which is something to consider
if you specify the nature of the.
Actually.
If you specify the nature of the being
that you want to bring into being,
then you radically increased the
probability that that's what will occur.
And of course you all know that because
you regard yourself at least to some
degree as active creative agents,
right?
Your fundamental attitude towards yourself
at at least in the manner that you
act towards yourself is that you wake up
in the morning and you have a landscape
of possibilities that lay themselves
open to you and you make choices between
those possibilities and determined in
consequence how the world is going to
manifest itself.
So you confront a field of potential.
That's a good way of thinking about it
and through your choices you determine
which elements of that potential are
going to concretize them selves into the
real world and you are
very unhappy with yourself.
If you don't do that properly and
you're very unhappy with other people.
If they don't do that properly and
If they don't treat you like
that's what you're like.
Because part of what
you demand from people,
let's say in terms of sheer civility is
that they act towards you is if you're
the locus of voluntary choice in a world
of potential and you are braid each
other for that as well.
If you have children and parents,
your parents will say to you,
if you're fortunate,
you're not living up to your potential,
which is actually a compliment in a sense,
even though it's also a judgment and
the compliment is I know perfectly well
that you could be more than you are and
you're hang your head if you have any
sense and you'll think like you think
in relationship to your own conscience,
that yes,
I have a lot of potential that are
not fully realizing and that actually
constitutes a transgression
against the good and I don't.
I don't think I've ever met
anyone who doesn't believe that.
If you.
If you have a reasonable
conversation with them,
it just seems self evident.
I mean,
maybe now and then you meet someone
who's narcissistically self satisfied,
but then they're narcissistic
and that's not good.
That as a,
as a medium to longterm strategy,
that's a catastrophe
that ends in disaster.
You know,
it's a short term.
It protects people,
but longterm it's.
It's not good in the least,
and of course other people
don't appreciate it as well.
Rule 11 is don't bother children when
they're skateboarding and that's actually
a discussion of courage,
of encouragement more more specifically
because I've been trying to understand,
for example,
what role parents play in the lives of
their children and I would say this is a
role that that that is a fundamental
importance as well as attempting to guide
your children so that they
act in a socially desirable
manner so that the world
opens itself up to them.
You also want to encourage them,
which is not the same as sheltering them.
It's not the same at all.
And to encourage someone
is to say something like or
to act out something like,
look,
kid,
as you move,
the world's already difficult because
the world isn't easy for children anymore
than it's easy for adults.
The difficulties are they're not the same.
Their child's size difficulties,
but there are still difficulties.
The world is a very hard place and it's
a bitter place in many ways and it's not
only a hard and bitter place.
It's also touched with betrayal and
malevolence and that's the fundamental
bottom line,
but there's something in you that is
capable of taking that full on and
transcending it and that encouragement.
You say,
well,
as difficult as things are,
you're up to the challenge and to
interfere with children when they're
skateboarding.
For example,
when they're doing,
let's say in advisably dangerous
things which kids of course do.
If they're skateboarding.
To interfere with that is to interfere
with the child's willingness to
voluntarily expose themselves to the
risks that they need to expose themselves
to in order to develop this sort of
competence that allows them to thrive in a
world they cannot be sheltered from.
And so to interfere with children when
they're taking the necessary risks is not
love or empathy,
but cowardice on the part of parents
and it's deeply damaging to children.
And I can tell you as a
clinical psychologist,
I've never had a client come to
my office in all the hundreds in,
in,
in all of the hundreds of encounters
I've had with people in my office.
I've never had a client say my
parents made me to independent.
Right?
That hasn't happened once.
Right now my parents made me too dependent
or I conspired with my parents to
perpetuate my dependence.
That happened all the time.
So there's a rule of thumb,
which I think is a good one,
which I believe is often
applied in nursing homes by
people who work in nursing
homes,
which is of course a very difficult job.
And the rule is do not do anything
for anyone they can do for themselves.
And the reason for that is
that it's a form of theft,
right?
You don't first all,
if you.
If you do something for someone and
it facilitates their movement forward,
then they moved forward
because you help them.
Which is something I was very
careful about as a therapist.
I don't want to give my
clients advice first.
It might fail,
in which case they are going to
pay for my advice and second,
if it succeeds,
then I get to be the successful one and
I don't want to steal the success from
my clients.
That's a bad idea.
I want to help them figure out what it
is that they should aim at and then help
plot out a strategy for attaining that
and but I want to ensure that it's their
destiny,
not something I'm imposing,
and of course the imposition of that
sort of thing is the hallmark of a bad,
I would say therapeutic relationship,
but also a bad relationship period.
Right?
So one of the things you want
to do with your partners,
your spouse or your say your husband
or wife and also with your children,
is to listen to them so that you can
figure out what their problems are and
figure out with them because they're
going to figure that out by communicating
and then perhaps aid them in
the development of a strategy,
but you have to ensure very carefully
that you're not imposing your own
structure in a manner that's
going to steal from them.
What's rightfully theirs,
so,
so rule 11 is an injunction to courage
as the fundamental because you could say,
well,
what's the antidote to
the catastrophe of life?
And one answer might be safety.
It's like,
well,
you know,
look everyone sensible enough to know
that a certain amount of provision for
safety is,
is worthwhile.
You should probably wear your seat belts
when you're driving around in your car
because why take fool hardy risks,
but given that there
is no security in life,
in the final analysis than encouragement
is a much better medication than
sheltering and so,
and that was,
that's,
that's I think in keeping with the idea
that what life is essentially is not a
place to attain happiness or even to aim
for happiness even though you should be
grateful if someone
comes along now and then,
but a call to something like adventure.
And I think that's the proper
way of conceptualizing it.
Certainly if you go watch a story,
a movie,
read a book,
something like that.
If you encounter a
narrative that's gripping,
whether it's a romance or
a classic adventure story,
then the element of it that's
gripping is the adventure,
and so to portray life as an adventure
in romance and and in the world is the
proper way to portray
it and the way that you
facilitate the adventure
is through encouragement.
I had a client once.
I really liked him.
He was a good guy,
smart guy,
good looking young guy,
had everything going for him.
You know,
he's a good musician.
He was a talented athlete,
but he hadn't been encouraged.
I wouldn't say
he told me about his
relationship with his girlfriend.
He said
his girlfriend wanted to go
biking around southern Ontario.
She was about 19 or 20 and he thought
he might join her and when she went and
talked to her parents,
they made every provision possible to
help her prepare for the journey to make
sure her bike was in good shape,
to make sure she had the right
equipment to help her plot out a route,
and when he went and
talked to his parents,
all they did was worried that he was
going to get hurt and like he might get
hurt because people get hurt,
but they didn't understand that they
were choosing between the hurt that he
might encounter by going out in
the world and having an adventure,
let's say with his girlfriend or the hurt
that he would encounter by staying at
home,
towering in his basement,
under the protection of
his over loving parents.
Well,
his girlfriend ventured
bravely into the world.
You think,
well,
which of those two things is
most likely to be damaging?
And their answer to that is,
well,
his parents wouldn't
worry as much as if he.
If he was in the basement
and that's the wrong worry.
Even because they should worry more.
Not less so in rural 12,
his pedicab when you encounter one on
the street and it's a oddly enough,
a meditation on fragility.
It's a discussion of what you do when
you don't know what to do and that's
really when things have
gone badly for you.
When you face a terrible tragedy in your
own personal life or in your familiar
life or perhaps even in
the life of your community.
When things come crowding
in and you too quickly in,
in,
in the case of a death in the family or
a terrible illness or the collapse of a
dream or any of the things
that can flip your world.
Upside down is how do you cope with that.
And that chapter contains discussion
of the necessity of narrowing your
timeframe.
Because sometimes the right way to
look at the world is across years and
sometimes it's across months and
when things are more out of control,
perhaps it's across days
and when things are really.
When you're really up against the wall,
it's a car across hours or even minutes
and during those minutes then you
concentrate on doing as well as you can.
With what's right in front of you for
the longest unit of time that you can
tolerate conceptualizing.
Maybe that's what you do at someone's
deathbed and while you're doing that and
suffering away madly,
then you also take the time to
appreciate everything you can.
That manifests itself,
that allows itself to be appreciated.
And so that's the metaphor of the cat,
I suppose.
And so that's the 12 rules and I'll
return to rule one which is stand up
straight with your shoulders back,
and I'm going to use it as platform
for laying out the abstractions that I
talked to at the beginning of the lecture.
So some of you might be familiar
with the central Dallas symbol.
It's a symbol of dao and
dow is a very strange word.
It doesn't have an easily
translatable single meaning,
at least in English.
It means a variety of things.
That means the path of life.
So that would mean that the path that you
take as you move forward through life,
but it would mean more
also the proper path.
So it's that.
It's the proper path through life.
So the idea dow is a symbol of reality
and one of the things that means is the
path you take through life,
and so there's an implicit idea there
that the fundamental reality of life is
the path you take through life.
It's not a materialist idea,
it's a different kind of idea.
It's the idea that life is a journey while
we're mobile creatures and we're on a
journey and the best way to conceptualize
reality is as the place that you
journey through,
and the question is,
well,
what are the elements?
What are the constituent elements of
the place that you journey through?
Because that's also part of Dow and the
Dallas believed that that's the Yin and
Yang,
and Yin is the black serpent because
those are two serpent's head to head that
make up the totality of the world,
and the black serpent is Yin and Yang.
Yin is feminine.
Classically speaking,
from the Taoist perspective,
it's a symbolic representation.
It doesn't mean that women
are Yin and that men,
men aren't.
It's not that it's an attempt to use
sexual symbolism to represent a deeper
underlying reality,
and Yang is masculine.
Urine is dark and night and there's a
white.in the black serpent and there's a
black.in the white serpent.
The serpent is the daytime and masculinity
and it's the interplay between those
two things that make up reality and
one can transform into the other at any
moment,
and so that's the Taoist idea of reality,
and so there's Yin and Yang and they
make up the world and the question is
perhaps act question is,
well,
what exactly does that mean?
Well,
it actually means something.
It's a kind of abstraction and
it's actually an incredibly
helpful obstruction.
Once you understand the abstraction,
it might be the most real
abstraction there is.
So I'm going to lay out a
little bit on layout for you,
a little bit about what
these two domains refer to,
and then I'm going to make a case that
they're real and then I'm going to tell
you what it means that they're real.
So you could think of Yin as chaos.
Now we need to know what chaos is now.
Chaos is what God made the world
out of at the beginning of time.
So one of the things that chaos is this,
something like potential
and so you can imagine,
and this is not how we think as modern
people because we tend to think in a
materialist way,
but it is how we act
and as I said already,
you act as if you confront potential and
you treat potential as if it's real and
if your attitude towards it confers
on you a certain moral obligation,
which is why you know what people mean
when they say you're not living up to
your potential.
No one ever says,
well what do you mean by potential?
Not unless they're being argumentative,
because you already know
and very few people say,
while I'm fully living up to my potential.
So you admit to the reality that
undergirds that conception that makes that
question and possibility immediately.
The potential is while
potential is the future.
That's part of it and we
believe in the future.
We believe that it exists.
Even though it isn't here
and it's not measurable.
It's.
It only exists as a potential
set of realizable possibilities.
That's what the future is and
it's really what we contend with.
We don't really contend
with the present precisely.
We Orient Ourselves towards the future
and the future comes at us from every
direction and we we,
we decide as we encounter the future,
which parts of it we're going to interact
with and how we're going to construct
the present and the past as
a consequence of doing that,
and so part of chaos is potential
and that's the positive part.
It's like if you're in a bind,
what you look for is potential.
Is there another way of
conceptualizing this?
Do I have a different way of of acting?
Can I make another plan?
Is there something that I'm not taking
into account that would make this
terrible situation tolerable?
That's all an attempt to to call upon
potential and to use it to transfigure a
reality that's intolerable and maybe it's
intolerable because of the way you're
conceptualizing it.
Now.
I'm not being naive about that.
I understand perfectly well that people
can find themselves so badly cornered in
life that they're basically
done no matter what they do.
People obviously developed fatal illnesses
and they die and their businesses
collapsed and genuinely terrible things
can happen to you that aren't your
fault,
that you can't fix.
I'm not saying that you can just
gerrymander the world by changing your
attitude.
It's not that straightforward,
but I am saying that you have a tremendous
ability to transform the landscape of
possibility that reveals itself in
front of you and that when things are
terrible,
that's your best bet.
It doesn't mean it will succeed.
It just means you don't have
a better option and so chaos.
That potential is also something that
manifests itself in a terrible manner.
So imagine this.
This is a good way of thinking about it.
So imagine that you have
an intimate relationship.
Let's say a marriage and the marriage
is predicated on trust and fidelity,
which is a variant of trust,
and that trust and fidelity
is an axiom of your memories.
You might think,
well,
what does that mean?
It's like,
well,
let's play it out.
Imagine you've been married for 10 years
and then your wife tells you that she
has had three affairs.
Each of them lasted three years and the
last one has lasted five years and it's
still ongoing.
Or maybe you discover that,
okay,
so then you might say,
well,
what happens then?
Well,
what happens is that everything
you thought was wrong.
Right,
and this is such an interesting thing
because it actually means you had the past
and you think the past is fixed.
It's done with.
That's why it's the past,
but all of a sudden you find out that
one of the things that you thought about
the past and it happens to be a very
important thing wasn't true at all.
And so what that means is that whole
past that you thought was what it was,
wasn't what it was at all.
And so it transforms itself from an
actuality into potential and most of that
potential is negative.
Unless you're relieved that
your wife had an affair.
Well,
but that's an important consideration
because you know you can imagine a
situation where your marriage
is dreadfully unhappy and
you're just looking for
an excuse to leave.
It's possible that that revelation,
even though it would be shocking,
would also come with a fair bit of relief,
and so this potential,
the potential that manifests
itself even when it's unexpected,
it doesn't only necessarily
manifest itself in a negative guys,
it can also free,
you know,
and and if your marriage was unhappy,
even if you wanted to cling to it,
if your marriage wasn't happy and the
betrayal was revealed and you're divorced
and you set yourself up in two years,
you might be in a better
place than you were.
It's not a pathway I'm
recommending by the way.
I'm just saying that it's more
complicated than it looks.
That's the introduction
of chaos into order.
Right?
And the the,
the oldest story we have is something
like order is susceptible to disruption by
chaos and the human.
That the fundamental demand that's made
on the human being is to contend with
the chaos that disrupts order.
Not to live in order and
not to live in chaos,
but to be able to contend with
the chaos that disrupts order.
And so when you encourage your children,
for example,
what you're doing is encouraging them
to become the masters of the chaos that
can disrupt order rather
than denizens of order,
which makes them tyrants
or Denisons of chaos,
which makes them nihilistic and hopeless.
So you train your children,
you encourage your children and yourself
and your partner if you have any sense
to be a master of emergent chaos
and to be able to contend with that.
And so,
so chaos has potential
and it's this disruptive.
It's the capacity of the infinite world
to disrupt your finite considerations.
That's another way of looking at it.
Another way of looking at it is it's the
serpent in the garden of Eden and the
reason that that story is set up the
way it is is because it's trying to
represent that there is no place
that so bounded and secure,
even if it's set up by God himself that
doesn't have an agent of chaos inside
it.
It's exactly the same idea that
the Dallas put forward with their,
with their symbolic representation.
It's just portrayed in a different manner.
The question is,
well,
what do you do in the garden given that
there's a snake in it and the answer to
that is something like you become the
master of snakes and so and that's a deep
idea.
That's the same idea as confronting
the dragon and getting the treasure.
That's the same idea as going to the
bottom of the ocean and rescuing your
father from the belly of the whale.
It's the same idea and that's an element
in the greatest of stories in the
greatest of stories is heroic,
heroic story and the heroic story is to
voluntarily confront the unknown when it
manifests itself and together something
of value as a consequence and to share
it with the community.
There isn't a story that's more emblematic
of what it means to be human then
that,
that that is us.
That's our best bet.
All right,
so chaos.
Chaos is the catastrophe that
will suddenly enter your life.
Chaos is the flood.
That's definitely coming.
Chaos is the ever present possibility
of apocalypse in your personal life and
your familiar life and in
this broader social life,
right?
Chaos is the consequence of your finite
fragility existing in a world that's
beyond you.
Chaos is potential.
Chaos is what lies before you.
Chaos is what you can call on when you
need something to rescue yourself from
malfunctioning order.
It's a permanent element of existence.
Chaos is what you don't know.
Chaos is what's outside the fire.
Chaos is what's outside
the walls of your house.
the walls of your town.
Chaos is what's outside of
the borders of your country.
All of that is chaos and potential
order
order is where you are when what you're
doing is working in the manner that you
intended,
okay?
It's a very specific definition.
How do you know that you
know what you're doing?
Well,
you don't because you don't know what
you're doing because you don't know
everything.
Everything you do is bounded by ignorance
while you still have to operate in the
world,
and so what you do is you make finite
plans and the new execute plans and then
you execute strategies to to make
those plans manifest themselves,
and if the plan's manifest
themselves the way that you desired,
then you regard your
knowledge as sufficient.
That's your definition of truth and it's
the only definition of truth that you
can use because you don't have everything
at hand and when you're aware what
you're doing is working that's
order and you might think,
well,
I should just stay there because that's
a comfortable place to be and there's a
certain amount of truth to
that except for one thing.
If you've
defined a domain of order and
you stand in it and you wait,
the disorder will enter all by
itself because things aren't static.
Things change all the time and your
attempt to bind yourself within a static
structure is destined to fail because
everything around you is in flux and the
thing that you parceled out as permanent
will transform itself across time.
Here's an example.
Let's say you're a perfectly well adapted
11 year old and it's actually possible
to meet 11 year old children are often
very delightful because they're like
adult children,
they're not teenagers.
They're like they're.
They're the most mature form of children
and they can be really delightful
people and then like three years later
you hate them and and the reason for that
is that of course,
as soon as they hit puberty,
which is the emergence of chaos into the,
into the already developed
childhood structures,
really the emergence of sexuality into
a structure that didn't have to adapt to
sexuality and maybe even the emergence
of aggression to some degree,
but mostly sexuality.
If the child maintains only the 11 year
old personality by the time they're 16,
they're no longer a
delightful 11 year old.
There are very immature 16 year old and
the reason that I'm pointing that out is
because just because something works for
you now doesn't mean it's going to work
for you five years from now and
so in order to remain stable,
you can't be stagnant.
They're not the same thing.
Stability is a dynamic,
not a not something static,
and so not only do you
have to be where you are,
but you have to be going to where you're
going and you have to be participating
in both of those things actively,
so it's stability plus transformation
and I would say that manifests itself.
You know when you're there because
that manifests itself as meaningful.
That's actually the instinct of meaning,
which is an instinct and perhaps the
deepest instinct is precisely the instinct
that tells you when were you
are a sufficiently stable,
but you're transforming yourself at a
sufficient rate to keep up with everything
that's changing and you know that
because if you're at your job,
you might say to yourself,
well,
my job is really secure,
but it's not very
challenging and you think,
well,
why do you care about that?
It's very secure and
the answer to that is,
well,
if it's not challenging,
it's deadening in a sense,
right?
The spirit goes out of it.
If it's not challenging,
you need to be challenged and why is that?
Well,
the answer is,
well,
tomorrow is coming and whoever you are
now isn't enough for tomorrow and so
today you also have to be preparing for
tomorrow and next week and next year,
and if your job isn't challenging than
it isn't doing that for you and you find
it deadening,
not meaningful,
and the reason for that is that it
violates your most essential instinct and
your most essential instinct
is the instinct for meaning
and it signifies that.
It actually signifies that you have the
balance between chaos and order right
deeply,
right?
Which is why it's the most fundamental
of instincts because chaos in order are
the most real of things.
All right,
so you have the chaos that surrounds
you and in some some sense infinite in
scope,
and then you have the
order that you produce,
which is your mastery of it.
Well,
let's take order apart for a minute.
We want to think about the
structure of order and bill,
and I'm not saying that chaos
is bad in order as good.
I'm not saying that at all.
That's not the right way to look at it.
It's the balance.
It's the balance between them
that's of crucial importance.
They just take.
They exist as superordinate categories.
Whether you liked them or not
is really not that relevant.
They're they're,
they're fundamental constituent
elements of reality.
You might say,
well,
what's your evidence for that?
And I can tell you one piece of evidence
which I won't go into for for very much
time.
You have two hemispheres
and each in your brain,
the brain is composed of two hemispheres,
which implies something about
the nature of the world,
given that your brain is hypothetically
adapted to the structure of the world.
It's not just your brain because
animal brains have the same fundamental
structure,
this bifurcated structure and the
bifurcation indicates that there's two
fundamental realities because otherwise
why would you need a bifurcated
structure or maybe you needed triune
brain or one that's divided into four,
but that isn't what you have.
You have one that's divided into two and
if your working definition of reality
is scientific,
biological,
let's say,
then your definition of reality is
reality is that which shapes life.
You can't actually do better than
that from a Darwinian perspective,
and if the reality that shaped life
produced a bifurcated representational
structure,
then that implies that the proper way
to represent reality and perhaps that
reality itself is in fact bifurcated and
I believe it's bifurcated in the manner
I just described and the neurological
evidence for that is actually quite
overwhelming.
It's come from multiple sources,
some of them Russian,
some of them American.
That's where most of
the work has been done.
Your left hemisphere is specialized for
operation in those situations that you
know and understand,
and your right hemisphere is specialized
for operation in those situations that
you neither know nor understand,
and the proper way to orient yourself
in life is to get the balance between
those two sets of operations correct,
and the way that manifests itself in
your subjective experiences as meaningful
engagement.
And so that's not a bad first pass.
What would you say?
Justification for the view that these
two domains are the most real domains.
Okay,
so order.
What is order?
Well,
if you just sit there and do nothing,
that will be chaos.
Why?
Well,
because you'll.
You'll suffer and die.
That's what will happen.
So without action on your part.
Deterioration in death is a certainty.
Okay,
so you need to act.
While when we built on an action
platform been where the consequence of
3 billion years of evolution for action,
action,
movement forward in the face of
necessity is the prime dictum of life.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
Were embodied action.
What do you have to do when you act?
Well,
at minimum,
you have to do whatever
keeps you able to act.
These are truisms,
right?
I mean,
you have to have something to eat.
You have to have some fresh water.
You need some shelter,
right?
You need some companionship.
You need a sexual partner,
you need children,
you need play.
You need to be touched,
and I mean,
I actually mean need by the way.
People deprived to play go insane.
People who aren't touched,
die.
These things are necessary.
Well,
assuming that survival
itself is necessary,
but we'll start with that.
We'll start with the assumption that just
sitting there and suffering and dying
is not the right solution.
Okay?
So you have to act in the world,
you have to act in the world that in a
manner that stops you from deteriorating
and dying at minimum,
and that means that you have to address
the problems that are intrinsic to that
destiny.
Now you have all sorts
of systems that evolved,
have evolved to help you do that.
Motivational systems we have
to eat so you get hungry.
You have to find water in and consume it.
So you get thirsty,
you get lonely,
you get curious.
There's there's,
there's specialized biological
systems that are very,
very old.
You get aggressive,
you get afraid,
you,
you suffer pain,
all those specialized systems for all
of those unit directional systems of
orientation in the and they
help you figure out what to do.
So when you're hungry,
it's time to eat and
when you're thirsty it's,
it's time to drink.
And when your lonesome,
it's time to seek out some companionship.
And you have specialized
systems that help you do that,
but they're not enough because,
well,
they're not very bright.
That's one way of looking at it.
They're kind of uni dimensional and you
also have the problem of organizing all
of them.
It's like,
well,
you have to eat now and you have to
drink now and you need a companion.
It's probably time to play and you have
to do something about shelter and there
isn't just you right now.
There's you now and tomorrow and
next week and a year from now,
five years from now,
so you have to plan across all those
stretches of time and there isn't just you
now in the future,
you there's you plus your family and your
community and so all of that has to be
taken into account while you're plotting.
Your movement forward is very,
very complicated.
You have all these problems to solve
simultaneously and your motivational
systems,
anger,
hunger and so forth can help you
solve one of those problems now,
but not all of them permanently.
That requires higher cognitive function
and that's part of what drove the
evolution of our complex
cognitive systems.
That's how do you propagate the game
across time in a complex environment.
The left hemisphere operates when,
where,
when,
what you're doing works and so a lot of
what you do during your life is to keep
your right hemisphere off.
People don't like it
going on accidentally.
It's the home of negative emotion.
It's the home of pain and anxiety.
It's the thing that turns on and freezes
you in your tracks when something that
you deeply did not expect happens and it
prepares you to deal with the onslaught
of what you didn't expect.
Now it's not all bad news because to
use the right hemisphere in a judicious
manner is also something that
adds intrigue and interest
in artistic expression
and all sorts of positive
things to your life.
So because potential is not only negative,
it's also positive.
It can be,
it can be dealt with in ways that are
deeply enriching and meaningful order.
Okay,
so you have to do something.
Otherwise the consequences are dire.
To do something,
you have to value something.
It's a definitional issue because to do
something is to act out the proposition
that the thing you're doing,
the thing you're aiming at,
let's say is preferable to the thing you
have and preferable means you'll do it
so those things are tied
together so tightly.
You can't disentangle them.
If you say,
I'm aiming at x,
but I don't value it,
then there's something wrong with the
way that you're conceptualizing the
statement because to aim at something
and to work to bring it into existence is
the same as valuing it,
and if you say,
well,
I don't value it,
then something's out of kilter.
Either you're acting out a false hood
or you don't know what you're talking
about.
It's one of those two things and you
meet people like that are deeply confused
there.
Their action patterns and their
verbal self representation don't Mesh,
but that doesn't mean that
they're critics of value.
It just means that
they're deeply confused,
so you have to act or you suffer.
In order to act,
you have to have a value structure
because to act you have to value one thing
more than another,
which means that you have to
inhabit a structure of value.
You have to,
okay,
so you need a structure value because
it's the antidote to catastrophe.
Now,
if you act out a structure
of values socially,
which you will because you're social,
you're not going to pursue your aims
in isolation because you're not.
You're not a solitary animal.
You're a social animal,
you're a tribal animal,
deeply tribal.
We live in groups.
We live in families,
we live in communities.
We live in large societies were social
at every level of analysis and we've been
social for as long as we've been primates,
so maybe that's,
that's at least 6 million years
and it might be more like $60,
million years.
It's really a long time,
so it's not an arbitrary
social construction.
It's far,
far deeper than that.
Now what happens when you act out
a structure of value in this social
environment,
you produce a hierarchy inevitably.
Well,
let's think it through.
Why?
Well,
let's say that you say that one thing
is more worth doing than another,
whatever it happens to me,
and then you tell a bunch of people
about what you're doing and they decided
that they're going to come along and
help you do this thing that's valuable
because they also think it's valuable and
maybe you get 20 people together to do
this thing.
Whatever it happens to me and the first
thing you discover is that some of the
people are way better at doing whatever
it is that they're doing than other
people.
So and that and who knows why that is
because it depends on what you chose to
do.
You know?
If you chose a then it would
be a different group of
people who were good at it.
Then if you chose B,
because people differ in their abilities,
but one thing you will not escape
from if you make an organization to do
something valuable is the brute fact
that it will be a minority of the people
who are good at doing it.
And there's actually a law.
It's called price's law
and it's a real law.
Even governs the size of cities and the
massive stars and the heights of plants
in the jungle.
It just doesn't govern human interactions.
And price's law says that the square root
of the number of people engaged in an
enterprise,
we'll do half the work.
So if you have 10 people doing something,
three of them will do half the work,
but if you have 100
people doing something,
then 10 of them will do half the work.
And if you have 10,000 people
doing something than 100
of them will do half the
work.
And uh,
you know how wealth distributes itself
such that a minority of people have most
of the money.
Twelve 85 richest people in the world
have as much money as the bottom two and a
half billion.
It's something like that.
And everybody goes,
oh my God,
the one percent.
It's like,
well,
first of all,
you're all the one percent.
So get over yourself because
you're know western European,
roughly speaking and by world
current world standards.
And certainly by historical standards,
you're all well ensconced
in the one percent.
So if that's a problem,
well it's a problem for all of
you and some of you might be,
you know,
richer than that,
but that doesn't mean all of
you aren't in the same boat.
Fundamentally,
the fact that wealth aggregates in the
hands of a small number of people is part
of the general expression of price's law.
There's nothing special about
the distribution of money.
You see the same thing in every creative
domain mean how many of you have have
recorded a
gold record?
How many looks like zero up?
There's one,
one person,
okay,
there's 850 people in here.
So there's one in the thousands.
So that's one 10th of one percent,
something like that.
How many of you have
written a piano concerto?
Uh,
how bout painted a painting that's
hanging in a national museum?
Oh look,
it's none of view again,
right?
Well,
and how many of you have been a
member of a professional sports team?
Okay,
look up one one.
So that's one in 10,000.
Well,
you get the point here.
if there was a couple,
there is.
Okay.
So looks like it's easier to be a
member of a professional sports team
or my or my audience is is
biased the samples biased,
but,
but it is the case.
If you look at high levels of creative
achievement of the sort of just described
that they characterize it
staggering minority of people.
And so the rule is is that you produce
a value system which you better produce
because otherwise you suffer
and die and it isn't only that,
only that.
It's like,
look,
here's something else you all
know as far as I can tell,
we start with the idea that there's an
intrinsic chaotic element to life and
that includes the inevitability of
suffering and malevolence betrayal at the
hands of yourself and other people.
So that's the baseline.
And that's intolerable in many ways
because life is in many ways intolerable.
And the question is,
well,
what do you do in the face of
something that's intolerable?
And the answer is when you try to
find something that justifies it,
right?
You want to have something that gets you
the hell out of bed in the morning and
not just any old morning but a morning
when your father has Alzheimer's disease
and your daughter has an incurable illness
because you need something to get out
of bed for in those mornings too,
and that better be the that you found in
life and if the purpose is going to be
such that it gets you out
of bed in those mornings,
it better be a pretty damn noble purpose
because otherwise why would you bother?
And so not only do you
need a value structure,
you need one that's of sufficient tension,
let's say,
or sufficient value or sufficient
nobility so that it's worth suffering for
because you're going to suffer and you
better have something that makes the
suffering justifiable.
And so not only do you need the value
structure so that you don't just
deteriorate and die.
You need the value structure so that
when the flood comes in your life as it
certainly will,
that you have built a vessel that will
sustain you through the catastrophe.
And that's not this pursuit of happiness.
It's not even the pursuit of security,
it's none of that.
It's the orientation that you've managed
to produce in your own life towards a
higher good that's so high that it's
worth bearing the burden of being to
produce.
You implement that in the world.
You produce a hierarchy.
Now you might say,
well,
and then you have the problem of hierarchy
and the problem of hierarchy is a
very few people are going to be very
good at whatever that hierarchy does and
then you have the second
problem with hierarchy,
which is the problem I just laid out
when I asked you about your spectacular
levels of attainment and
found out that they were very.
It was very unlikely.
I'm not saying that you haven't
attained worthwhile things.
That's not my point.
My point is is that very high levels of
attainment or extraordinarily rare and
that's an inevitability.
As soon as you decide that something's
worth doing to inevitabilities,
people stack up at the top minority of
people stack up at the top and take most
of the proceeds,
whatever they happen to be
or deserve them or earn them,
whatever.
However,
I don't care how you conceptualize it and
almost everybody else stacks up at the
bottom,
and so the problem with hierarchies
is that even though they're necessary,
they tend to produce a situation where
most people stack up at the bottom,
and so that's the next thing
that we have to contend with.
You can't get rid of the hierarchies
because if you get rid of the hierarchies,
there's no value structure and
if there's no value structure,
not only do you deteriorate and die,
you want to deteriorate and die
and that's not a good solution.
But if you do generate a hierarchy,
then you have the
problem of the hierarchy.
And the problem is the hierarchy is
that it will dispossess most people now,
to the degree that the
postmodernists have something to say,
that's what they say is hierarchies,
dispossessed,
okay.
And then we can look at that clearly and
carefully and we can say that doesn't
mean a,
that hierarchies themselves are corrupt
or that we can dispense with them,
but it also doesn't mean that we have
no moral obligation to the dispossessed.
And we say,
well,
how do we deal with that politically,
conceptually and the
way we deal with that,
at least in part,
is to produce a political spectrum that
ranges from left to right that deals
with hierarchy and the problems
that hierarchies caused.
So one of the things that you can
reliably assume about someone who's on the
right is that they will be patriotically
in favor of the current hierarchy or
even more abstractly,
they're in favor of the idea of
hierarchy itself and you say,
well,
more power to the people on the right
because you need hierarchies so they
should support them.
But then you have to take the
people on the left who say,
yeah,
but what about the people who are
dispossessed by the hierarchy?
And what you have to say to them is,
yeah,
we actually have to do
something about that.
And you think,
well how do we do something about that?
And the answer is we don't actually know
because there's no permanent solution
to the problem of
dispossession by the hierarchy.
We don't know how to fix it.
Say,
well,
we could flatten hierarchies.
It's like not without
disrupting the value structure.
That's a price you don't want to pay.
Well,
we can take from the top
and put it at the bottom.
It's like,
yes,
hypothetically we could,
but it turns out that when
you try that in practice,
it's very,
very easy to rapidly go too far and
then what you end up with not is less
dispossessed.
You end up with no one who has anything
and that's not a good solution to the
problem of scarcity,
right?
To make everyone equally
dead or equally starving,
which is essentially what the communist
states did across the entirety of the
20th century is not the proper way
to address the problem of hierarchy.
Now it has to be addressed
even if you're on the right,
because here's one thing that happens.
Hierarchies tend to Ossify,
you know,
because what happens is
that the people at the top,
maybe they got there by merit,
but it's easy for them to Gerrymander
the system so they can stay there without
merit.
Or perhaps their children can stay
there without merit or they can.
Or the hierarchy becomes corrupt so that
people who only use tyranny and power
can climate,
and so you don't have a hierarchy
of competence and value anymore.
You have a hierarchy of brute
power which looks like a tyranny,
so there's all sorts of
ways that hierarchies can
deteriorate and we have to be
awake to ensure that that doesn't occur.
Also,
if the hierarchy gets so steep that
everybody stacks up at zero and no one can
climb it,
which is basically the definition of
a malfunctioning tyranny than all the
people at the bottom rightly think,
well,
why don't we just destroy the game
because we're already at zero?
So what the hell do we have to lose?
And so one of the things that you want
to do if you're a sensible conservative,
is make sure that the hierarchy
maintains its routing and competence,
that it's transparent and that it's
climate double because otherwise it will
ossify in steepen and then
it will destroy itself.
And if you're a conservative and you
value stability and the hierarchy,
then you don't want to set up a situation
where the most likely outcome is that
the hierarchy destroys itself.
So so we can be intelligent about this.
We could say,
look,
don't be thinking.
You can get rid of hierarchies
they've been around.
This is why I wrote chapter one.
I talked about lobsters.
The reason I talked about them is because
not only is the hierarchical structure
itself as a permanent
feature of existence,
at least a third of a billion years old,
which by the way means that you
cannot attribute it to capitalism,
the free market or the
corrupt patriarchal west,
unless you're willing to make the
case that all three of those elements
contributed to the existence of
dominance hierarchies among crustaceans,
which seems highly unlikely.
So,
and this is actually something that's,
that you can think about it as an idea
that's actually directed towards the
productive left.
If you want to help the dispossessed,
don't blame the existence of hierarchies
on capitalism because it's wrong.
It's wrong that the problem
is way deeper than that.
And here's something else that's
very interesting about capitalism,
couple of things you might consider,
you know,
we have become spectacularly
wealthy since 18,
95,
right?
First in the West Icelands
at classic example.
I mean you guys are so much more wealthy
than you were a hundred years ago that
it's absolutely impossible to believe.
And so that's first happened in the west
to exponential economic growth starting
in about 1895.
There's a long tail.
I mean,
people were improving before that,
but it really kicked in around 18,
95 and first happened in the west and
now it's happening everywhere in the
world.
I don't know if you know this,
but you know,
the UN set a goal in 2000 to have the
level of absolute poverty in the world by
2015,
which is the fastest rate of
economic growth ever recorded.
We attained it in 2012,
three years ahead of the
most optimistic projections.
Right?
And so people are being lifted out of
poverty at a rate that has never been seen
in the history of the world hooked to
the power grids provided with cell phones
provided with free,
with access to fresh water provided
with access to medications that decrease
child mortality.
Like if you look at the statistics,
there are so many things getting better
so fast you cannot even believe it.
And that's,
and here's the consequences as far
as as far as the data indicate of the
operation of the free market system,
which does produce inequality.
That's the thing,
but as far as I can tell,
the only system that has ever produced
wealth and as law or has every system
produces inequality,
but the only system we
know of that produces,
produces wealth and
inequality is the free market.
So here's a question for
everyone left and right.
How many units of inequality will you
tolerate to produce one unit of wealth?
And if the answer is zero,
then you've gone too far.
You're outside the
appropriate political debate.
That's the wrong answer.
And if you try to impose that all there
will be as mayhem because the price we
pay for wealth is inequality.
Now that doesn't mean that you can let
inequality run to its ultimate extreme
because then you run
into the other problem,
which is the monopoly problem.
You've all played monopoly.
I presume what happens
in every monopoly game,
if you lay it out,
everyone stacks out at zero
up at zero except one person.
Now,
if you play it 50 times,
you'll find that it's hardly ever the
same person because it's basically a game
of chance and there's a fair
bit of chance by the way,
operating in the distribution
of money in the world.
It's not all chance,
but there's a fair bit of chance.
But the logical conclusion to a hierarchy
that can play itself out totally is
that one person has everything
and everyone else has nothing.
Obviously that's not a useful outcome.
So,
so you know,
in the way there are ways that
we fix that in our society.
We have progressive tax policies and
you can argue about their utility,
but that's one way of
rectifying it potentially.
Another way of rectifying is
that we don't have one game,
right in a pluralistic society,
we have many,
many games that people can play and so
if you can't be a successful lawyer,
then maybe you could be a successful
plumber and if you can't be a successful
plumber,
maybe you can run this small
restaurant or you know,
there's a diversity of games.
And so that's a good way of,
of allowing,
of increasing the robustness of the
system so that you don't get hierarchies
that are so steep that they
collapsed in upon themselves.
And so those are sophisticated approaches
and perhaps your other approaches to.
But it's an intractable problem.
It says in the New Testament,
it's one of the things you'd swear would
be edited out because it's such a harsh
statement.
Uh,
the poor will be with us always.
Well,
what's that in reference to?
It's also in reference
to the matthew principle,
which is another new testament statement
and happens to be an economic axiom to
those who have everything more will
be given from those who have nothing.
Everything will be taken.
That's the structure of the world and
you can't lay it at the feet of the West.
It's the structure of the world.
Now that means we have to contend with
it and it's not an easy thing to contend
with and part of the reason that we have
a continual political dialogue and that
we need to have a continual political
dialogue is to make sure that our
hierarchies exist and remain intact,
but don't become so steep and corrupt
that they destroy themselves and you need
a left and a right for that,
and if that means the left half has
to admit that hierarchies are not only
necessary but valuable and the right has
to admit that despite their necessity
and value,
they tend to stack people up at the
bottom and that actually constitutes a
continual problem.
You see that in.
You see that in the old testament because
one of the things that happens in the
old testament is Israel struggles
up to state and empire status.
Six Times.
It struggles out of the chaos,
up to empire status,
and then it gets corrupt.
It loses the way.
It isn't balancing things
between chaos and order properly.
The kings get arrogant is so to the
people and they forget their relationship
with God.
That's another way of thinking about it,
and then a profit comes up and says,
you aren't paying enough attention
to the widows and the orphans.
You better look out because
that displeases God and the
Israelites who are stiff
necked and arrogant think
what's God going to do to us,
which is not a very wise way of thinking
and so they don't take the steps
necessary to rectify their deviation
from the proper path and they get
absolutely flattened and the consequences
of that last for generations like
seven generations,
and then they struggle their way up to
something approximating empire status
again and exactly the same thing happens.
They forget and they collapse and
there's six stories like that in the Old
Testament.
It's all documented by a man named
Northrop Frye who is a Canadian literary
critic who wrote a couple
of books on the Bible.
One called the great code and the
other called words with power,
which I would highly recommend.
It's an analysis of the
Bible as literature.
Brilliant for those of you who might
be interested in union thinking,
fries thinking is a nice adjunct,
so alright,
so,
so that's the nature of the world.
Order chaos and order,
and your goal is to keep those,
the relationship between those two
things optimized and you do that by doing
what's meaningful,
not what's expedient.
That's rule six and you ensure that you
have the world construed properly by
following rule number eight,
which is tell the truth
or at least don't lie.
You don't want a path.
All the guys,
the instinct that orients you in the
world and you will pathologize it by
engaging in habitual deceit,
and the reason you do that is
when you practice something,
you build structures that specialize in
that and then they run automatically.
So if you're living a lie,
which is a very common
thing for people to do,
then you're building
neurological mechanisms that
view the world through that
lie and once they're built,
they're you and good luck unbuilding them.
It's very,
very difficult.
That's in part what happens to people
who are addicted by the way they build
mechanisms of search,
neurological structures that are focused
on the drug and those systems are alive
and all they want is the drug and they're,
they're not.
It's not psychological.
Exactly.
It's psychophysiological.
Don't build structures of
cognition predicated on
deception because you will pay
for it.
And so if you're going to guide your
life with the orientation of the instinct
of meaning,
then you have to be very careful with
what you say and write and think because
every time you say or
write or think something,
you build a little neurological structure
that specialized for that and it
participates in this parsing of the world.
So all right,
chaos and order.
Then you can say the
order orders a hierarchy.
Okay,
so here's the next question.
Next two questions is order a hierarchy
and then a subsidiary question would be,
if order is a hierarchy,
what's what?
Either what is at the top of the hierarchy
or what should be at the top of the
hierarchy.
The hierarchy is a structure value.
So that's the question is what
should be of ultimate value.
Okay.
So now we're going to take
that apart a little bit.
The first thing I would say,
his order is not a hierarchy.
Order is a set of hierarchies.
That's a different thing.
So
I'll tell you how to think about that.
I think.
So imagine you have a child and
they're playing soccer and uh,
your child is a pretty good soccer player.
No,
I'll tell you a different story.
This actually happened.
So I'm going to tell you a story about
hockey and I'm since I'm Canadian.
What the hell?
I might as well tell you
a story about hockey.
Um,
my son played hockey.
He still plays hockey.
He's a pretty good hockey player and
my wife and I used to go watch him play
hockey.
There was an arena just down the
street from us and there was a nice
neighborhood league there.
And so they'd start the kids into teams
and then they let them play a few demo
games and if any team was getting stomped
flat or any other team was winning too
much,
then they'd rebalance the teams.
So that they were
approximately equal in skill.
So that was the sorting of the teams.
So,
um,
and then they,
then they were on their teams and then
they'd play 15 games during the regular
season.
They didn't have a little tournament,
see who won and it was really good.
It was good friendly league.
And so my son's team was in,
I think it was the championship game,
if I remember correctly.
And uh,
there's one kid on his team who is
the best player on the team by quite a
margin,
you know,
he was very fast on his feet.
He could,
he could skate rings
around a lot of the kids.
He was good at stick handling.
He was a good hockey player.
But um,
he had some problems.
This kid,
one problem was he wouldn't pass the puck.
Now you think,
well,
why the hell should you pass the park
if you're the best hockey player?
Which is pretty much what he thought.
And the answer is,
well,
you're part of a team,
right?
You want to be the best
person on the team,
fair enough and you want
to win the hockey game.
But you also want to what make
your team mates better players.
How's that?
Maybe you even want to meet
the people on other teams,
better players I knew,
now I know that's going
a little bit too far,
but you certainly want to make your
teammates better players and you might
think,
well why would you do that?
Because if there are better than maybe
you won't be the best while that's a bone
headed way of looking at the
world because first of all,
if you amp up the competition around you,
maybe that'll motivate you to be even
better and it's a hell of a way to win by
making everyone else lose.
That's not much of a victory.
And so if you have any sense,
you pass the damn park.
Even if you're the better player,
especially you especially do that.
Let's say you've got a
comfortable two goal lead,
well then maybe you can risk taking the
time away from that specific game to
build up the confidence,
confidence and ability of your teammates.
And then maybe everybody thinks that
you're a bit of a leader and they make you
team captain.
Not even so much because
you're the best hockey player,
but because.
Well,
because why?
That's the question.
Okay.
So we're watching the game and it's pretty
exciting and it's real close game and
it's like three to three and it's a minute
left and now their team zips down the
nice and scores and really brilliant goal.
And so my son's team loses except that
they were in the championship and it was
a really good game.
So you know whether or not they
lost is not all that obvious.
They lost that game,
but you know,
there's a broader context
to take into consideration.
Okay.
So this kid,
the star goes off the ice and he takes
his hockey stick and he smashes it onto
the cement and he's all angry
because as far as he was concerned,
he was robbed.
And maybe that's because of his useless
teammates who he didn't really spend any
time helping by the way.
And maybe it's because the referees were
unfair and who the hell knows why but
it wasn't fair and his idiot farther
rushes over to him and consoles him in on
his loss and supports them in his notion
that he was robbed and I thought you
unspeakable son of a bitch
because he was an arrogant narcissist
and it was way more important to him that
he had a son who was a star then that
he had a son who is a good person
and that's absolutely inexcusable.
He made the wrong choice.
He sacrificed his son Soul in part to
help them save face for a hockey game.
That's not acceptable.
Okay?
So here's what you tell your children.
It doesn't matter whether you win or lose,
it matters how you play the game.
And so that's what the father should have
told the son and he should have meant
it.
And even better,
he should have known what it meant.
But who knows what that means because
you tell your children that and maybe
they're not so happy because they lost
a game and they look at you like you're
an alien.
And they think,
well,
what the hell do you mean by that?
Because obviously it matters whether you
win and it does matter whether you win.
So what is it that you
mean when you say that?
And your kid asks,
well,
what do you mean by that?
And you go,
well,
I don't know what it means,
but it's a good rule.
So what do you mean by that?
Here's what you mean.
And it relates to rule five,
which is don't make your.
Don't let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them because other
people will dislike them.
That and you don't want other people to
dislike your children unless you want
your children to inhabit a world
where everyone dislikes them.
And maybe you do because you don't like
your children and maybe you don't like
your children because you let them behave
in ways that makes you not like them.
And so the way you take revenge is by
not correcting them so that other people
will punish them because you don't
have the courage to discipline them.
And if you think that
people don't play that game,
then you don't know much about people
because they play that game all the time.
All right?
So
it matters how you play the game.
It doesn't matter whether you win or lose.
Let's take that apart.
Well,
so the first thing is,
and this goes back to the idea of the
hierarchy is order a hierarchy and the
answer is no,
it's a set of all hierarchies.
Or You could say it's the,
it's the set of all possible
hierarchies because you know in,
in a society at a given time,
there's hierarchies that function.
But that transforms.
And then there's new
hierarchies that function.
The specifics of the hierarchies change,
but the fact of the hierarchies remains.
And so you can imagine a hierarchy as
a metal structure that consists of a
multitude of possible hierarchies.
And that's going to
change as life continues.
And so what you want for your children
is not to be the master of hierarchy you
want for your children to be the master
of the set of all possible hierarchies,
because then no matter how things change,
they're ready say,
well,
how is it that you get
ready for things to change?
And the answer is play so that
people will invite you to play.
Right?
And there's a rule for,
for,
for children,
for raising children,
and it really,
it's a rule.
One of the things you can
do with your children.
This is something good for men because
men are more likely to do this than
women.
Although women can do it too,
but men are more likely to do it.
It's good for children to
engage in rough and tumble play,
play fighting.
First of all,
if you have children and you've
played with them physically,
you know that they absolutely love it.
They will rough and tumble play with you
until you are completely exhausted and
they're not even vaguely ready to quit.
They have an inexhaustible
hunger for it and they like it.
They like to be pushed to the edge.
So I knew this when I was a new father,
partly because I read work
by a man named Jaak Panksepp,
who was a genius,
an effect of neuroscientists,
one of the world's great neuroscientists,
perhaps the world's
greatest neuroscientists,
although there's four or five
people that might compete with him.
He wrote a book called
affective neuroscience,
emotional neural science,
which is a work of real genius.
He discovered the play circuit in
mammals because there's a separate place
circuit in mammals,
a specialized circuit,
and he did a lot of work on rats and
showing that in order for a rat to become
socialized because rats are highly social,
they had to engage in iterative
bouts of rough and tumble play.
And here's a cool thing.
It's a ridiculously cool thing.
So,
and this has to do in some sense with the
postmodern critique of the patriarchal
tyranny.
So if you take two juvenile rats,
males,
and
you imagine you give them
an opportunity to play.
So you throw two of them into a little
player in and you let them wrestle,
okay?
The next time that you bring
them to the same place,
you can measure how much work they'll
do to open the door to the arena,
how many times they'll push a button,
say to open the door or how hard,
how hard they'll pull if you tie a string
spring to their tail and so you can
get an estimate of their
motivation because the more
motivated they are to play
at,
the harder they'll work and rats will
work really hard to play so you know that
they want to play.
I mean assuming that you're willing to
accept the fact that if you work for
something,
you want it.
It's like an operational definition,
so rats will work to play.
Now if you let the rats out in the play
arena and one rat is 10 percent bigger
than the other,
then that rat will win.
You might say,
well,
what does winning mean?
Rats wrestle like people wrestle.
They even pin each other and they
manifest play behavior to begin with,
like dogs playing in a park.
You know how a dog looks
when it wants to play.
Sort of hunkers down a little bit.
It looks up at you like expectancy
expectedly kind of moved back and forth,
which is like,
okay human,
I'm ready to play and if you have
any sense and you know how to play,
then you look at the dog and you sort of
go like this and the dog goes like this
and you cuff the dog not too hard and
the dog bites you not too hard and then
you can play and you're
both happy with that.
And kids can do that with dogs because
kids understand dogs and dogs and kids
knew how to play.
If if your dog can play,
then you should not own a dog.
You're not smart enough to own a dog.
So it's true.
And if you have a dog that can't play,
then don't have a kid.
Right?
It's true.
Stupidest dog I ever saw was owned
by a psychologist that was really
embarrassing.
So okay,
so you put the rat to rats together and
there's the 10 percent bigger route and
there's the 10 percent smaller rat and
the 10 percent bigger rat stomps the
small rat and pins him.
So he went.
And so now you're a postmodernist doing
the experiment and you say powerful,
tyrannical rat dominates hierarchy.
Really?
That's what you conclude and
to experiment and you're.
And it looks correct because powerful,
dominant rat dominated and one,
it's like,
okay,
cep,
for one thing,
rats live with rats.
No wonder they're not
psychopathic individuals
wandering from isolated community
die slated community.
They know all the other rats and that
means they have to keep playing with them.
And the rules for playing with someone
30 times are not the same as the rules
for playing with someone once.
So Pang sap had the rats play
repeatedly and what he observed was,
okay,
now the next time you
put those rats together,
the situation's a little different.
The little rat comes bouncing out
and does the playful dog thing too.
The big rat.
So now the rule is you're
the little rat you lost.
You have to be the creature
that invites to play.
That's now your status.
So you bounced around and you
know the big rats all cool.
And he's smoking a cigarette
and doesn't want to,
doesn't want to play,
but they'll flick it away
at some point and think,
all right,
what the hell you know?
And so then he gets in it and so neat
can stomp the little route again because
he's a bigger rat.
If the big Grad doesn't let the little
rat win 30 percent of the time across
repeated play boats,
then the little rat won't
ask him to play anymore.
You think,
well,
if you think about you
don't think so what?
You don't think.
Why did Jaak Panksepp waste
his time studying play in rats?
You Think,
oh my God,
that's an absolute miracle.
Because it shows you that there's an
ethic of fairplay that emerges as a
consequence of repeated bouts of play.
Even among rats.
It's so basic.
It isn't even human.
That ethic,
they ethic of fairplay
is deeper than human.
It's real.
And it's the ethic that
governs iterated interactions.
And it's not just in rats
that we've seen this.
So you know,
chimpanzees are pretty damn brutal.
They're way more brutal than you think.
And they're really,
really strong.
Maybe six times as
strong as an adult male.
Now there's the estimates vary,
but there are plenty strong enough to
tear you to bits and that happens now and
then people have chimps for pets and they
become adults and it's like don't mess
with the chimp because it'll tear you to
pieces and so and chimps are brutal and
this is interesting because they're our
closest relatives and so Jane Goodall
discovered in the 19 seventies that
rats or tribe or chimps are tribal.
They live in tribal groups like we do and
they have a territory that's the known
territory and there's a
perimeter that's the unknown.
That's chaos and other
chimpanzees inhabit the chaos.
Foreign Chimpanzees and the juvenile
chimps patrol the perimeters in groups of
four or five,
and if they spy us,
a foreign chimp or two of them,
if they outnumber them
because they can't count,
but they have a sense of quantity.
If five chimps come
across to foreign chimps,
they will tear them to bits and
I actually mean that literally.
That's what they do and chimps also hunt.
They hunt colobus monkeys and they
weigh about 40 pounds and they're quite
carnivorous and they will eat them alive.
Well,
they're screaming,
so there isn't a lot of empathy
regulating chimp aggression,
which is something to think about when
you think about human beings because it's
not obvious what regulates our
aggression and you might think,
well,
it's your conscience and like,
yeah,
maybe it's your conscience
and maybe it's something else.
You read the book,
have you read the rape
of Nanking for example,
and you'll start wondering very,
very rapidly about whether people
have any conscience at all.
So that's a story of absolutely
atrocious Japanese behavior in China at,
at the beginning of World War
II and it's a horrifying book.
So read it with caution,
but it's very instructive.
So anyways,
the chimps,
the chimps are very brutal
creatures and so you might think,
well,
let's look at a chimp hierarchy because
chimps have dominance hierarchies in
there.
Basically male dominated,
although there are lots of
powerful female chimps say,
okay,
who becomes the dominant chimp?
And the answer might be,
and this would be the postmodern answer,
the most powerful tyrannical brutal
chimp rules because it's power that moves
you up the hierarchy.
It's like that happened
sometimes among chimps,
but you know what happens to tyron chimps,
they have an off day and to
subordinate chimps each three quarters,
the size gang up to make a one and a half
super chimp and then they tear him to
pieces.
Right?
So here's the rule.
If you're a chimp
tyrants meet bloody ends.
So how do you conduct yourself as a
chimp if you want to be at the top of the
hierarchy and have preferential access
to the things that being at the top of
the hierarchy would give you and
answer is engage in mutually reciprocal
interactions with your peers.
The chimps that rise to the top,
that stay there stable and also have
the most stable functioning by the way,
are the ones that have friends that are
long term and permanent and engage in
reciprocal interactions not
only with their friends,
but also with the females and the infants.
And so even among chimps,
patriarchal tyranny,
a is not the norm and B is not the
proper motive approaching the situation,
and so that speaks to a broader ethic.
The same kind of ethic that is spoken
to with regards to the rat studies have
play behavior and you can see this sort
of thing throughout the animal kingdom.
There's A.
There's a pattern of reciprocal
interaction that seems to stabilize social
animals that isn't
predicated on brute force.
Now maybe the simpler the animal,
the more it's predicated on brute force,
but we are by no means simple animals
and the idea that our hierarchies are
fundamentally tyrannical.
The patriarchy,
which is a word that nobody who thinks
carefully should ever use casually.
That term is predicated
on the idea that a,
that are hierarchies are tyrannical,
which they aren't.
Although they can become that way and
be that the most reliable means to
attaining status within a hierarchy is
through the expression of power and both
of those things are wrong.
They're wrong.
And nonetheless,
that's the primary theory of the
social sciences and the humanities,
and enough of that,
we've,
we have enough data to indicate that
none of that's sufficiently sophisticated
to constitute a reasonable
explanation of the world.
So we should dispense with
it as fast as possible.
All it's doing is dividing us into tribes
and it's not solving the problems that
it's hypothetically intended to solve.
So,
okay,
so now back to the question.
So
there isn't that hierarchy.
There's a set of hierarchies
and it's like the set of games.
So here's what you're telling your child
when you say it doesn't matter whether
you win or lose,
it matters how you play the game.
What you're telling them
is life is not a game.
It's not even a sequence
of the same games.
It's multiple sequences
of different games.
And if you want to be a successful
player in the set of multiple sequence of
different games,
then you have to adopt
a higher order ethic.
And you don't subordinate that ethic
to victory in any one game ever.
So you put the manner in which
you play above your victory in,
in each instance.
And the reason that that produces the
best possible outcome for you is that you
get invited to play the
largest number of games.
And so let's go back to rule five.
Don't let your children do anything
that makes you dislike them.
Okay?
So let's say you like your.
Let's say you love your children
and you want the best for them.
You detach yourself and a
little bit and you think,
well,
I'm not going to be around forever.
And they're going to deal with
a lot of different people,
single people,
like individuals,
groups of people,
children and adults.
And what they have to be prepared for is
to interact with that set of people in
the best possible manner.
Because.
And so what do you want?
Well,
let's say your child's two,
and it's still pretty egocentric
because children two year olds are quite
egocentric.
They can't share yet.
They don't really learn how to share
in any technical sense till were about
three.
It's hard for them to learn to share
between two and four.
They learn to share and to play.
And the way they learn
is by at least in part,
by engaging in reciprocal
interactions with their parents.
Now,
what is it that it.
What is it?
That's your job when you're
socializing a child who's two to four,
you have to do it between the
ages of two and four by the way,
because if you don't manage
it by the time they're four,
then you might as well give up
because it isn't going to happen.
And the literature on antisocial behavior
in children is crystal clear on this
point.
If your child's antisocial
at for you failed.
And there isn't anything
that can be done about it.
It's a dismal literature.
And believe me,
psychologists and sociologists
and anthropologists and
criminologists have tried
for like six decades to figure out how
to remediate antisocial behavior in older
children and adolescents
and they haven't managed it.
So.
So two between two and four is crucial.
You want to help your child become the
sort of person that other children want
to play with.
And the reason you want to do
that is because from four onward,
other children are the primary
agents of socialization.
And so if your children are
accepted by other children,
then they're on their way because
other children will socialize them.
It doesn't mean you're
not important as a parent,
but it means they find their peers who
are at the same developmental level as
them and they start to reciprocally
socialize one another and they do that
through play.
And so if you've prepared your
child to be a great play companion,
then you can just stand
back and let it happen.
And you have to be around
when something breaks down.
When the system doesn't work properly,
you have to be there as a resource.
But basically you can sort of push
them out onto the playground and say,
you know,
you know what to do.
Go play and play is of absolutely crucial
importance as documented by people
like John Piaget.
So you're trying to make your child
maximally attractive as a play partner.
And the ethic there is while the world
is made out of a sequence of hierarchies
that transform.
And so you want your child to be
the sort of person who's invited.
Participate in what ever hierarchy
organizes itself and how and what should a
child be like to do that
while they have to be.
Be Reciprocal.
Take turns right.
You don't always get to pick the game.
You have to find out what
other people want to do.
They have to want to play too.
Like there's all these sophisticated
ethical rules that go around play and you
know if you're playing with some of you
have played with kids that aren't fun to
play with,
well what do they like?
If something doesn't go their way,
what happens?
They have an emotional outburst so they
revert to the behavior of a ill prepared
two year old.
They have a temper tantrum.
They burst into tears.
They thrashed around on the floor.
It's not fun because when you play,
if you don't lose some times
that no one else ever wins,
so who the hell is going to
play with someone like that?
A downtrodden victim,
that's all.
It's not.
No kid with any sense is
going to put up with that.
All they do,
and this is exactly what kids are like,
if they find out that their potential
play partner is a whiny two year old,
even though therefore they just start
playing and they go find another kid,
that's exactly what happens,
and so if you want that for your kid,
then make sure that they're whiny
and bitter every time they lose.
A good way to do that is to never let
them lose at anything so they don't get
any practice.
Well,
I don't want my kid to lose.
It's wrong.
You don't want to.
You don't want your kid to lose
in an unsophisticated manner.
That's not the same thing at all.
And if you think the way you accomplish
that is by never having your kid lose,
then well then,
well then we're back to the.
You shouldn't even own a dog problem.
All right,
so then you might take apart.
What does it mean to be
a desirable play partner?
Assuming you're gonna play reciprocal,
repeated games across all
sorts of different contexts.
Well,
there's a,
there's a whole aspect
that emerges from that.
See Nature back in the late 18 hundreds.
He was the first person to kind of caught
onto this sort of thing because until
then,
people tended to think of morality as
something that was invented rationally and
then imposed from the top down,
but nature being a very intelligent
observer noted that well,
that wasn't really the case.
There was a ethic already built into
human interactions that we all acted out,
but that we didn't really
understand very well.
So here's a way to think about that.
So imagine you're watching a wolf
pack and wolves compete for dominance.
And so the way they do that is they
basically have a play fight about it.
Now it's this fairly serious play fight.
And so two wolves that are engaged in
a dominance dispute will sort of sand
sideways to each other.
You know how cats do that?
Do you ever watched two caps
fight cats stand sideways,
think,
well,
why does it cat stand
sideways when it's fighting?
It's because a sideways cat is
a bigger cat than a hand on cat.
So the cat's trying to intimidate the
other cat so it stand sideways and it
puffs itself up including its tail.
And the reason it does that is so that
it looks bigger because one cat isn't.
Cats don't want to fight,
they want to threaten
until one cat backs down.
And so they puff themselves up and they
make horrible noises and they face off
against each other,
but they don't want to fight because
the two cats that are fighting my damage
each other,
then a third cat comes in and like wins.
It's a stupid strategy.
So it's,
it is.
It's so.
Most animals don't like to fight
because they might damage to themselves.
And then another interloper.
We'll just,
when it's a stupid strategy and human
beings are quite a bit like that.
We do a lot of posturing
and defensive display,
an aggressive display and all that.
But we don't fight very often for the,
for the same reasons.
And it's only when those other mechanisms
breakdown that we actually fight.
So
what happens in a wolf dispute is this,
the wolves square off and they amp up
the threats in the hope that one of the
wolves will back the hell down.
Because what'll happen is the
wolf will chicken out one of them.
And then when it does,
it rolls over and shows its neck.
Why?
Well,
because when wolves hunt,
they go for the neck generally,
like wolves are quite cruel
creatures in some sense.
And they'll actually
eat moose standing up.
But generally speaking,
if they can manage it,
they go for the throat and
they'll bring the animal down.
And so what the wolf
is basically saying is,
well you scared me half to death.
I'm a useful move.
I'm a useless moose.
You might as well tear up my neck.
And other wolf says,
yeah,
you're pretty detestable and
you're kind of like a moose,
but I might need you to hunt tomorrow
so I know I can tear out your neck,
but I won't.
And then the defeated Wolf stands up and
he's not very happy and he's kind of a
low status wolf,
but at least he's still got his neck.
And the victor wolf gets to be high
status wolf and he gets to go hunting with
his partner the next day.
And so you might think,
well,
wolves have a complex procedural morality
and morality is don't tear the neck
out of your,
out of the out of the creature
you defeat that's wrong.
And then you might say,
well,
that's the rule that will follow,
but that's wrong because wolves don't
follow rules because wolves don't have
rules because they don't have language
and they don't think not like us.
They act like they have rules.
They act so that if you watch them act,
you could label what
they're doing with the rule.
That's how we got our rules.
We acted out and ethic and then we.
And then we coded it in stories.
That's what our religious
stories are there.
The consequence of us watching what it
is that we do when we act ethically and
then transforming that into a story and
everyone's intent on that story exists
absolutely intent on the
story of good versus evil,
let's say,
because that's the fundamental story.
And why do you want to watch that story?
Because you want to know how to be the
victor in the set of all possible games.
And that's what that story's about
and that's what movies are about.
And that's what books are about,
announced what religious
narratives are about.
That's what everything that grips
us at a literary level is about.
And the reason that it grips this is
because that's what the world is made of
and that's what we need to know.
So then you might think.
So here's something to think about.
I'll give you a symbolic
representation of this.
Okay?
So there's this idea in Christianity,
and I'm not talking about this
from a religious perspective,
okay,
I'm talking about this
from an anthropological
perspective or a biological
perspective or a
that'll do an anthropological or a
bylaw or psychological perspective.
So there's this idea in Christianity that
Christ is Christ is the king of kings.
Okay?
So I'm going to take that apart.
So imagine that you have a hierarchy,
whatever it is,
and there's someone at the top of it.
And so that person has the attributes
necessary to be at the top of that
hierarchy.
And maybe it's a hockey team and you go
home and you tell a story about how the
best hockey player on your team played
while they were being the best hockey
player.
It's a little hero narrative,
so little fragment of a hero
narrative and maybe it's hockey,
soccer,
plumbing,
law,
business,
art.
There's all these hierarchies.
And then there's the thing
that's at the top of all of them.
And the thing that's all the at the top
of all of them has something in common.
That's whatever it is that's in common
across all the things that are at the
top.
So imagine this,
okay,
so you could think about this.
Imagine that you're a novelist and you
want to distill some characters and you
want the good evil character because
what the hell good is your book without a
good evil character and you want a good,
good character because
the same problem applies.
You don't want to just tell
a story about some guy's Day,
right?
You don't want to say,
well,
John woke up at six and then he smacked
his lips four times in blank 20 times
and then he swung his feet over across
the bed and walked into the bathroom.
Because who cares about any of that?
You don't need to know that because you
know how to move your mouth and cough
and walk to the bathroom.
It's not helpful.
You want to distillation.
You want the novelist who have watched
a bunch of people and abstracted out
someone who's good in a way that's good
across a bunch of people and you want
him to have abstracted out someone who's
evil that's abstracted across a bunch
of evil characters,
so you see that in hamlet for example.
You see that Dostoevsky where the where
the characters are bigger than life and
you want them bigger than life because
you want it distilled so that you can
learn from it and what you're
learning is that ethic.
Okay,
so that imagine that you
have 100 hierarchies,
just mundane hierarchies.
Then you take the people at the top of
all those hierarchies and say that you
group them into groups of 10.
Okay,
so you take 10 admirable
people and then you say,
well,
we're going to average across them and
we're going to come out with the most ad
with a compass it admirable person made.
Out of those 10,
you have 100 to begin with.
So let's say you have a
thousand to begin with.
You distill them to 100 admirable people.
Then you take that hundred
admirable people in,
you distill them into 10.
Then you take those 10 admirable people
and you distill them into one and what
that one is is what's admirable across
the entire set of admirable people.
That's a divine figure
in a mythological story.
That's what it is.
And so the Christian ideas,
Christ is the king of kings
and that's what it means.
You go into a cathedral and the
cathedral is across by the way,
and the cross is the place where suffering
is accepted and the cross is a dome
over it.
Then that's the sky.
Okay?
So there's an idea in the cathedral and
the idea is that the place of the cross,
which is where suffering occurs,
is the center of the universe,
which is the Dome,
and then you look up at the Dome and
you see this figure staring down at you.
That's the king of kings and
that's how to behave in the world.
That's what that image represents.
And you think,
well,
what does it mean?
Well,
here's a way of unpacking it and this is
associated with its associated with the
idea of how to behave across the
set of all possible hierarchies.
Well,
what should you do?
according to rule one,
you should stand up straight
with your shoulders back.
Okay?
Now the people who have been,
some of the people who've
been criticizing me say,
well,
because I pointed out
that hierarchies exist.
I'm justifying them.
It's like pointing out that something
exists is not the same as justifying it.
It's just pointing out that it exists
and pointing out that it exists without
justifying.
It is certainly not saying that the way
to attain dominance in a hierarchy is
through power.
Was the other thing that
I've been criticized for,
which is not what I'm saying.
In fact,
I'm not saying that.
No,
I'm not even saying that a little bit.
It's exactly the opposite
of what I'm saying.
Say,
well,
what if you stand up straight
with your shoulders back?
Isn't that a powerful stance?
And the answer is,
well,
actually no.
A powerful stance is this,
right?
Well,
not really because I'm
not very good at it,
but if I knew what I was doing,
this would be it and I put myself sideways
so I'm not much of a target and I'm
ready for attack.
Okay,
that's not this dance.
This dance is different.
Right,
and that that isn't this dance either.
This is a defensive crouch.
This is what happens if
you're depressed and anxious,
right?
This dance is,
I'm willing to take what
the world throws at me.
Right in.
That might be the trials and tribulations
that are associated with the hierarchy
because that's a tough
battle in and of itself,
but it also might be all the terrible
unknown things that are going to come your
way.
What's the right attitude is stand the
hell up with some courage and take it
right voluntarily with courage,
so it's actually a stance
of maximal vulnerability,
vulnerability adopted voluntarily.
That's what the crucifix represents.
Just so you know,
it represents the willingness to take on
the suffering of the world voluntarily,
the whole thing,
and that's associated with whatever
at the top of the hierarchy.
So the idea is the best possible strategy
that you have to be successful across
the set of all possible hierarchies is
to maximally accept the fact that your
vote,
that you're vulnerable to accept
that as the price of being,
and that's the essential message.
It's not only the message of Christianity
by the way you see this sort of idea
expressed in all sorts of
religious structures in the
daoists to return to them
say,
well,
where should you be in the world?
The world is made out of the catastrophe
of chaos and the tyranny of order.
Where do you stand in that place?
And the answer is with one foot
in chaos and one foot in order.
That's the line down the middle.
That's the Tao.
That's the way,
that's the point of meaning.
It's the same place that's
at the center of a cathedral.
It's the same idea.
You stand there because you're secure
because you have tradition and the power
of your civilization behind you and you
have one foot in chaos because that's
not enough and never will be,
and the instinct that puts you there is
the instinct of meaning and you can use
that as a guide and it's a
deep neurological instinct.
It's not some EPA phenomena.
It's the most real thing there is as far
as I can tell and associated with that
as a certain attitude towards life,
which is to venture courageously
out into the unknown,
is to put yourself on the line,
right,
to heed the call of adventure,
to risk yourself voluntarily.
You have no choice anyways,
right?
Because you're in this all the way.
There's no out that isn't death.
The full catastrophe is at your feet.
You can't evade or escape that,
but what you can do is choose how it
is that you're going to confront it,
and so rule one is to stand up straight
with your shoulders back and to
manifest,
and this is the thing that's
so amazing about this,
I think,
and that what lands are kind of ultimate
reality to the idea of positioning
yourself properly.
You might say,
well,
let's presume that you're
a very pessimistic person
or a very realistic person,
and you say,
well,
what's the fundamental reality of life?
You say,
well,
it's suffering and malevolence.
It's like,
okay,
it's a hard argument to forestall,
but I don't think it's true.
It's true,
but it's not.
It's not the final truth.
The final truth is,
despite the fact that that's true,
the ability of the human spirit to prevail
is more powerful than death and evil.
That's the truth,
and you know that you know that,
first of all,
you know that because you're ashamed
that you're not everything you could be.
You know that because the people that you
admire are people who manifest courage
in the diarist of straights and you
know that as well because when you meet
people like that and you're not like that,
they shame you.
That speaks to your
deepest possible instinct.
You know what you could be and you know
too that you see people contend with
situations that are so difficult that
it's truly a miracle that they can contend
with them.
You know,
when I think of people,
well,
I think the people who
work in funeral homes,
that's a good example.
That's hard,
right?
That's death and grief every day and
it's not something that you can avoid.
It's like it's right there.
It's as real as it can possibly be.
I'll tell you a story about that.
Had a client who was very afraid of being
alive and she wanted to sleep all the
time and she took sleeping pills and all
sorts of other things so that she could
evade the burden of being conscious and
she was a very good dreamer and she.
She wasn't doing well in university
and she had a dream one night that
Gypsy told her that she was actually
lucid during her dreams by the way,
and she could ask her dream characters
what they meant and they would tell her,
which was something I'd never
seen anyone else manage.
In any case,
she jumped up this gypsy that she met in
the forest and the Gypsy told her that
unless she learned to,
unless she could learn to
work in a slaughter house,
she never finished her degree
and so she told me that story.
I don't know if you know this,
but the classic treatment for people who
are afraid of things is to expose them
to what they're afraid of.
Which is a good lesson if you have
children because you want to expose your
children to challenges because
that makes them stronger.
It has to be done voluntarily,
but if you have posttraumatic
stress disorder,
let's say you're the of a vicious sexual
assault by a stranger and two years
later you have posttraumatic
stress disorder.
The most effective treatment is to get
you to relive the experience in as much
vivid detail as you possibly can and
experience all the emotions that occurred
while it was happening and if the.
If you do that,
the more upset you get when you do that,
if you do it voluntarily,
the faster you get better and
the longer you stay better,
and so it's a general rule of thumb in
psychotherapy is if someone's avoiding
something,
find out what they're avoiding,
break it into manageable pieces and have
them voluntarily expose themselves to
it and they will be cured.
And that's the dragon fight in,
in clinical practice,
find what you most want to what you most
need will be found where you least want
to look right.
That's a hell of a statement.
So she told me this dream and I thought,
well,
I don't know how to arrange for
you to work in a slaughter house.
That doesn't seem like very.
She wouldn't eat meat by the way.
She wouldn't go into a butcher store.
I took her into a butcher store once and
she had a very catastrophic reaction.
She couldn't handle it anyways.
I said,
well,
we can arrange the slaughterhouse thing.
Why don't you go away and for a while and
come back in a week and see if you can
come up with an alternative.
So,
uh,
she came back and she said,
I want to see an embalming.
And I thought,
Oh God,
okay,
how the hell am I going to arrange that?
So I phoned a couple of
funeral homes and I said,
look,
I've got this person who's really afraid
of death and she had this dream and I
told them the story and they said,
no problem,
bring her in.
And so I wasn't looking
forward to this by the way.
Um,
so we went and she was very,
very nervous because she certainly
didn't think she could handle that.
And as I said already,
I wasn't exactly thrilled about it either,
but in,
for a pound in,
for a penny in,
for a pound as they say.
So anyways,
we went to the funeral parlor and they
showed us around and we asked a bunch of
questions like,
how the hell did they
cope with their jobs?
Because that's just a mystery to me.
And they said,
well,
it was actually really useful for them
to guide people through the process of
grief and that their experience was
that that had given them a renewed
appreciation for life,
which is well
that would account for why they were able
to do it because it seems like a very
hard job.
And so we went into this room and watch
this embalming and I was about eight
feet away from this small room.
It's a pretty gruesome
operation as you might imagine.
And uh,
my client was sitting beside me and
I was watching her and watching the
embalming as well.
And for the first while she
was just looking to the side,
which was,
I'm not here and I certainly can't handle
that and no bloody wonder literally.
And so.
But then she would take the odd glance,
say she'd go like this and then look away.
And then as the minutes by,
but fairly rapidly,
she was spending more time watching and
less time looking away until she was
finally doing nothing but watching.
And then at some point she asked if she
could come in and put her hand on the
body,
and so they gave her a glove and she did
that and then she went and sat down and
she was quite quiet about all this
and quite quiet afterwards as well.
So what did she discover?
Well,
she didn't discover the death was,
wasn't horrible.
She didn't discover that and she didn't
discover the death wasn't terrifying
because it certainly was.
But what she did discover was that she
was a hell of a lot tougher than she
thought,
and,
and much quicker than
she would have believed.
And she went away thinking,
Huh,
look at that.
I did the thing I was
most afraid of doing.
And here I am.
Not only am I not more damaged than I was,
I'm actually better than I was.
And so from then on she
had a reference point.
Right?
Which is an interesting thing.
I think this is why primordial
people initiate their,
especially their young men,
because it sort of happens
automatically with young women.
They expose their young men to
something absolutely terrifying,
genuinely terrifying.
So for the rest of their lives,
they know the difference between what's
actually terrifying and what's just sort
of normal catastrophe because
you really need to know that,
right?
Because you need to know that you can
prevail and one of the things she learned
as a consequence of that exposure was
that she could prevail despite the
realities of life.
Of course,
that's what you want to teach
your children mostly by example,
is that they can prevail
despite the realities of life.
Of course,
that also means that you have to have
admitted to what the realities of life
are.
But the thing that's so
interesting about that.
Here's another story.
So you know the story of King
Arthur and the holy grail.
The holy grail is the ultimate value that
it's a symbol of whatever the ultimate
value is.
And King Arthur assembles is nights
around the round table and it's a round
table because they're all equal.
Despite the fact that they have a king,
they sit as equals at the round table and
they all decided to go off to seek for
the holy grail.
It's either the cup that Christ
drank out of at the last supper,
the cup that held his blood on the cross.
It's one of those two things.
It doesn't really matter.
It's a symbol of what's redemptive.
That's what the holy grail is,
so it's a representation
of the ultimate value.
The question is where do you go to seek
out what's of ultimate value and answer
in,
in the tail of of King Arthur and the
holy grail is that each night entered the
forest when they began their search at
the place that looks darkest to them.
So that's the thing is that it's necessary
if you're going to stand up straight
with your shoulders back to
confront the darkness of the world,
head on,
to take responsibility for the tragedy
of existence and for for malevolence.
That's what it means.
That's the what the Christian injunction
to take the sins of the world onto
yourself means it means
it's your bloody problem,
and to confront Satan in
the desert is the same idea,
is that not only do you have to take on
the tragedy of the world as if it's your
responsibility,
but you have to contend with the spirit
of malevolence while you're doing so,
and it's in doing that,
that you find your destiny.
That's where you find the highest of
possible values and that's the call and
that's the call to the nobility
of being because you might think,
well,
what could possibly justify
your life more thoroughly?
What could make you the best player
of all possible games than to take the
tragedy of the world onto your shoulders
and to fight with all your ability
against the malevolence in your own heart.
Thank you.
The first one I'll choose here.
Thank you for coming to speak with us.
What do you think of Iceland?
Well,
first of all,
thank you all for coming.
It's quite remarkable to see so many
people come out for such a serious
conversation.
It isn't exactly what you'd expect.
So,
um,
everyone has been ridiculously
hospitable to me and my family.
Um,
we've seen some beautiful things.
We were at the blue lagoon,
which was very impressive.
We went to the house today where Gorbachev
and Reagan met in 1996 and that was
very interesting.
I went and saw some rare manuscripts
at the university this morning,
a lager and his crew of people have been
very organized and you have a beautiful
little capital city that's extraordinarily
impressive and you've produced this
amazing venue and your country is
cruising along on all cylinders and it's a
hell of an achievement.
So that's what I think.
I,
I think that almost all the time
when I come to a European country,
it's amazing how well it works.
I mean,
it's a harsh place,
you know,
it's,
you made a lot of what you have and it
looks to me like it's just getting better
and so it's peaceful and productive and
civilized and beautiful and hospitable
and
good for you.
And thank you for inviting me.
I'm this one.
The next one is regarding
the headpieces on you.
Um,
when such an article is written,
what is your interpretation of the costs
or further potential explanations are
there for this phenomenon?
Well,
I think there's,
you know,
we could start with what I
might be contributing to it
now.
One thing I've had to learn,
I've had some interactions with
public exposure for probably
15 years because I worked a little bit
with a public television station in
Ontario before all this blew up.
My producer who was someone
who was very much on my side.
So I worked for a public affairs show
first of all as irregular panelist and
then as a columnist for a couple of years.
My producer,
who is the level headed guy
well versed in what worked
well in panel discussions,
told me to be very careful
about controlling my proclivity
towards anger because
it doesn't play very well publicly.
And so
no,
I kept trying to learn the doctrine
of minimal necessary force.
I mean,
I think that aggression is a
good thing if it's controlled.
I think it's a good antidote to fear.
I think it's one of the things that can
help you maintain your ground in the
face of resistance,
but it has to be applied very,
very judiciously and it isn't obvious
that I always do that as well as I might
end.
If you're going to deal with difficult
and dangerous and contentious issues,
then you're going to get
punished for your failures.
And so I'm trying to learn too
detach myself and to not,
not in a,
not in an I don't care way,
no,
but in a watchful way and to keep all of
that under control as much as possible
and to use minimal necessary force and
it's hard to learn to do that well.
And so to the degree that I don't do that,
then I instigate more
opposition than I might.
Now I have a hard time with that to some
degree because I do find some of what I
have been,
let's say opposing,
um,
what would you say
it,
it makes me deeply,
it disturbs me deeply and
makes me unhappy and ashamed.
That's particularly the case when I see
what's happening at the universities.
I'm not impressed by what's happening in
the social sciences and the humanities.
I'm not impressed with the postmodernists.
I'm not impressed with the Marxists and
I'm certainly not impressed with the
people or the theories that juxtapose
the two in this particularly ideological
brew that's been fermenting say since
the 19 sixties and so it's not easy to
maintain equanimity in the face of that,
but it doesn't matter because
it's still necessary to.
Do you think their ideology has permeated
all of media or because not all of it?
Yeah,
I mean that's the other thing is that,
and this is why dealing now,
now we can turn to what the
media might bring to this.
Well,
ideological,
ideological pre commitments.
That's certainly the case and
inability to see anything other than in
politicized terms.
Like I don't view that what I'm
doing as fundamentally political.
Actually.
In fact I don't view the battle that's
raging in the idiation substructure of
our society is fundamentally political.
I think it's deeper than political.
It's at least philosophical
and it's probably theological,
but the but the people
who've been pillaring me,
let's say who tend to be the
postmodern neo marxists types,
or at least leading in that direction
cannot conceptualize anything that isn't
political in their world.
There isn't anything that isn't political.
One of the things that you might consider,
for example,
is you know,
I've been perhaps represented as
an as an advocate of free speech,
and of course there's a lot of debate
about what free speech really is from the
radical leftist types and here's something
that you have to understand from the
collectivist perspective that
dominates the radical left.
There is no such thing as free speech.
It's not that they oppose it,
it's that it isn't a move in their game.
It doesn't exist.
So if you stand up and say,
I'm manifesting my
opinion as an individual,
then that's not a acceptable move
because you aren't an individual.
You're an Avatar of your dominant
group and whatever you otter,
regardless of why you think you're
honoring it or regardless of whether you
think it's your individual opinion is
nothing but a power move in your dominance
hierarchy and so it's not
like they oppose free speech.
It's that it doesn't exist in their
conceptual framework and so that's one of
the things that drives and they hit
pieces because I do believe in the
individual
and I do believe in free speech and
I do believe in a world outside the
conceptual realm,
all sorts of propositions that aren't
part and parcel of the postmodernist slash
neo Marxist game and they're
not very happy with that.
I'm not playing by the rules and so
they don't know what to do about that.
The simplest thing to do
is to call me far right,
are all right because then they can.
First of all,
that's an evil category and
that dispenses with that,
but it also means they don't
have to contend with any
of my arguments and that's
convenient,
so it's easier to demonize
than it is to contend.
So it doesn't seem to help them
because the more they scream,
the more people that actually listen
to you hear that are not far right.
You're not all thrive.
And they stopped believing them.
Well,
that's the other thing.
I've talked with my wife about
this because it's been in been.
It's produced a lot of tension in our
family because it's very stressful.
I mean,
for all sorts of reasons,
but that's certainly one of them,
you know,
I mean,
it's certainly not the case that when I
read a headpiece that I'm very pleased
about it and I'm often
quite worried about it.
Like the New York Times piece,
for example,
is a good example and it's idiot.
Um,
what would you call it?
insistence that I was promoting,
you know,
monogamy with the weapons of the
state of all the insane ideas.
I mean,
who the hell believes that
it's like some isis guys.
That's about it.
So,
so it's an,
it's a completely absurd accusation
and it certainly bore no resemblance to
anything that I meant.
But you know,
it's a powerful media organization and
lots of people warned me in the immediate
aftermath of that,
that it would be my downfall and
including people who were less,
they weren't fearful people.
And so it's very stressful.
So one question is,
well,
should I be doing
interviews like that at all?
Because one of the things I thought
is no written interviews only live
interviews,
only the whole thing.
So the one today you had is the last one.
Well see,
I don't know because the,
there's another side of it
which is decide you laid out.
It's like this happened with the,
some of you have seen the channel for
interview that I did with Kathy Newman.
Thank you.
You know when that was,
I would say that was a stressful interview
and I would say that the two weeks
after the interview we're
also very stressful because,
you know,
first of all there was the interview
and I thought they just cut it to seven
minutes and pillory me
and leave it at that.
But they it to seven
minutes and pilloried me.
And then they posted the whole interview,
which just shocked me,
but here's the shocking thing.
The people who posted that
interview thought it went well.
That's why they posted it.
They didn't think,
oh my God,
this is contentious.
We better put it out,
believe me.
They didn't think that that
is not what they thought.
They thought it went fine.
And so then there was this overwhelming
response to it and that was completely
unexpected.
And then the counter response was,
Peterson's army of alt right
trolls is victimizing Kathy Newman.
And that was.
That was the response of her employers,
the technical response,
because that's what they publish.
They said we had to call the
police to evaluate the threat.
It's like,
well,
so what anybody can call in
police to evaluate a threat.
It doesn't mean that the threat justified
police intervention or that there was
a threat.
It just meant that that's
how you responded to it.
And then they spun the
victim narrative for Kathy,
which was I think reprehensible.
Given that.
I don't know what Kathy Newman is exactly,
but she's not a bloody victim.
She's not powerless.
She's one of the most powerful women in
the United Kingdom and she has a salary
that's commensurate with that and good,
good for her.
That's absolutely fine,
but you don't get to have
that and also be a victim.
It's not the right way to play the game.
And so then a whole bunch of newspapers
laid out the story that poor Kathy was
being trolled by my legion of all right,
angry people,
but then the numbers started to mount,
you know,
an after it was like 4 million people.
It got the whole troll argument got hard
to sustain unless you think there are
like,
well now it's perhaps 30 million people
have watched either the whole thing or
major clips from it.
Maybe it's more than that.
It's hard to sustain the old troll
argument when it's 30 million people,
but it was very.
I thought that narrative was going
to prevail for a while that you know,
oh,
she got victimized and it was all these
terrible people that went after her.
But that collapsed.
But it's very stressful.
But,
and this is something that I've,
I've learned,
so I've been obsessing about another
statement in the New Testament for about
two years.
I've been trying to figure it out,
and it's,
it's the statement that you should turn
the other cheek and that's a tough one,
man,
because.
Well,
because first of all,
who wants to do that?
Because you want to
explode in righteous anger.
At least you want to defend yourself.
You want to do one of those things.
So what the hell does that mean?
And partly what it means is
if you're attack
and you're innocent,
and and look,
I'm not saying I'm like globally
innocent or anything like that,
but I'm not guilty of the accusations
that are levied at me or at least I not
guilty in the manner that the
accusations would indicate.
If you're being attacked and you're
not guilty of the accusations,
then the attacks
say more about the attacker
then their intended target.
And so,
so far I've been able to
withstand the attacks.
And the consequence of that is that it
said more about the attackers then about
meat.
And then the question is,
can I tolerate that because
it's still very stressful and
I very a waiver on that back and forth.
And then of course the other issue is
is that some people in the media of
pilloried me,
but many haven't.
You know,
there've been very many thoughtful people
that have written thoughtful pieces
about me.
There's a Canadian
consortium of 200 newspapers,
the post media group,
and they came out.
The entire group came out in favor
of my stance in relationship to bill
[inaudible] in Canada,
which was a speech,
a speech piece of legislation
that compelled speech and so
well,
so,
so far,
same with the protests.
When people come out
to protest against me.
The first video that went viral was a
protest at the University of Toronto and
after the protest was over that the pro,
the anti free speech,
people at the protests took the microphone
away in and blasted white noise and
made it impossible for anyone to speak
even though it was an open mic event.
So that got broadcast and then about
two hours after the event I went down to
talk to the cops.
To see if anybody had been
hurt or anything like that,
and then on the way back
into the university,
I go to Costco and buy half a dozen
like radical types and about 30 of their
hangers on and then there's a crowd of
people that I would say we're probably
supporting me that that gathered around
me and they went after me and videotaped
all of it on their cell phones and then
they posted that and the idea was that
that was going to do me in,
but what happened was the comments were
a 100 to one in favor of what I was say.
So that was another example where the
protests were more damaging to the
protestors then they were to me,
and that's been luckily fortunately,
miraculously all of that,
a recurrent pattern.
And so the question is whether or not
I can tolerate it and whether my family
can tolerate it.
And so far,
look,
if you're trying to do
something difficult,
let's say the right amount
of controversy isn't zero.
The question is how much controversy
can you handle and how much of the mud
that's thrown will stick.
And then how much of it deserves
to stick all of those things.
You go to scour your conscience
under those circumstances.
But
so I've been fortunate.
It seems like you've taken
on this dragon voluntarily.
It seems like from the beginning
you've known that this,
for example,
when you
spoke up against a
biddle see 16 in Canada,
you knew that this might become tough.
Well Guide taught people to negotiate
in my clinical practice for a long time.
You know,
I've had lots of clients,
many of those clients were female and
the are the goal in my consulting with
them was to double or triple
their salary within five years.
And so that wasn't
necessarily the only goal.
We discussed all sorts of goals,
but that was often one.
And so I was very accustomed to organizing
people to negotiate and there's,
if you want to negotiate,
there's a couple of rules.
The first rule is you
have to be able to say no.
And what no means is there isn't anything
you can do to me to get me to do that.
That's what no means.
Now,
like you can be.
You can have different degrees
of seriousness about no,
but if you're going to
negotiate with your boss,
say for a substantial raise,
no means if I don't get it,
then I will leave.
That's fundamentally and
leaving will cost you more than.
It's not a threat,
right?
It has to be the observation that me
leaving will cost you substantially more
than giving me the rates.
You have to be in a position to make that
case or you don't win the negotiation.
And so I always put my clients in a
position where if they went and asked for
something,
they were in a position to win because
we didn't go and ask before that.
So when I made the video
criticizing bill c 16,
I thought I'm not abiding by
this damn piece of legislation.
And then I thought,
well,
what does it mean that I'm not?
And I thought,
well,
I had multiple sources of income.
So I was reading.
I was reasonably positioned to
tolerate a fair bit of push back.
I mean,
I could've gotten wiped out.
You had things gone sideways,
but it would have been difficult to
take me out completely and I thought
there's no way I'm abiding
by this piece of legislation.
I was willing,
I thought through the
negative consequences now I
didn't of course think that
any of this would happen because this is
just completely preposterous and no one
could have possibly foreseen it,
but.
So I would say there were certain
things I faced in doing that,
but I couldn't have foreseen the
absolutely explosive consequences.
I'm not unhappy that I did it.
I would do it again.
I am still doing it.
I suppose.
So,
um,
which of your 12 rules
do you break most often?
I could probably still be better
at listening to people I like.
I have these,
um,
I do interviews with people.
I call them discussions because
they're not really interviews.
Probably they're not interviews
because I talked too much,
so I had to call them discussions.
But I would say the most common criticism
of those discussions is that I'm in,
I interrupt the people that I'm
discussing things with and until the
conversation probably a
little bit more towards me,
my thinking then there is now part of
that I think is my natural tendency
towards like I've always talked a
lot ever since I was like three,
like
continually.
So it's,
I'm there,
I'm verbally fluent,
you know,
it's part of my nature and extroverted.
But
you can always get better at listening,
you know?
And so I can listen and,
and I practiced that
because I'm a therapist.
But I would say that's probably the rule.
I break that rule nine,
like assume that the person you're
listening to know something you don't.
It's like I'm not as good at that yet as
I could be because I wouldn't get that
criticism if I was like,
it's not every comment or anything.
It's probably like every 20th
comment or every 30th comment,
but it's.
But it's still,
it's consistent.
And so every time I have
an interview I think,
okay,
I'm going to try to shut
up a little bit more.
But then I get excited about
what's happening and you know,
and talk too much.
One thing related to that,
sometimes you seem to go off on a tangent.
When you're discussing something,
you go into a,
you know,
something related to it,
then you come back to a
greater structure of things.
Um,
do you have you laid all this out before
you say it or do you just go from one
topic to another and they somehow
relate together and become whole?
Um,
both.
Both.
Yeah.
But so before I do a talk,
like I have to,
I think about the talk
all day before I do it,
like not 100 percent of the time,
but it's,
it's in my mind all the time and what
I'm trying to get as the basic narrative
and it's something you can only
use a metaphor to describe it.
So imagine you wanted to cross a swamp
and there were stones under the surface.
You need to know where the stones are
to get from one side of the swamp to the
other.
And so then that's what
I do in my imagination,
I think,
okay,
well there's this area I have to traverse
and there's stepping stones along the
way.
I need to know where they're located.
And so that might be like 12
points or something like that.
That's the rough path.
And then I have a whole corpus of stories
that fit each of those points and then
I can choose how I'm going
to weave those together.
But I have to remember where I'm going.
If I'm.
Well,
like if I'm healthy and
functioning properly,
then I can go way out on a
tangent and I can still remember,
Oh yes,
I have to tie that back to this
point and move to the next step.
So it's,
I like,
I think it's like jazz
improvisation essentially,
you know,
you have the melody and it,
it has to organize the melody has
to organize all the improvisation.
And then I have all these
stories that I know,
but I,
every time I tell this story I try to
vary it so that it brings in something I
haven't brought in before.
Integrate something,
you know,
like what are the things I
was trying to do tonight,
I've been trying to figure out for a
long time is how to integrate the idea of
the good player of games with the idea
of voluntarily shouldering you're the
catastrophe of life.
I know those are the same thing,
but it's not obvious why and I'm
still not completely obvious to me,
but I know that the connection exists
and I got a fair bit of fairways tonight
farther than I had at stacking
those concepts on top of each other.
So the other thing I'm always trying
to do is to take each of these sets of
ideas and to weave them
together more tightly,
but also to push them
further in their development.
So.
And you've been doing that on this tour.
Have you been developing your ideas?
Go.
Absolutely,
absolutely.
There's.
You can't give an
effective lecture without.
So
you don't deliver a talk to an audience.
First of all,
it's not app talk second,
you don't deliver it.
Third,
it isn't an audience
like all of that's wrong.
You talk to individuals in the audience
one at a time and they're representative
of the whole,
but you're not talking to the audience.
If you're afraid of public speaking,
it's [inaudible].
You're talking to the audience.
It's like,
forget about that.
You just talked to people.
You know how to do that,
and then you're not delivering a talk
because then it's a canned product.
You muscle just hand people pieces
of paper that they could read.
It's more efficient.
Why not do that?
What you're doing if you address people
properly is that you involve them in the
process of furthering exploration
of important concepts and you think,
well,
how can you do that?
Because they're sitting there passively.
It's like,
well,
you're not passive.
You're not verbal,
but when you're not passive,
like I listened,
I listened to whether or not
everyone's rustling around.
If you're rustling around,
then I'm not balancing
chaos in order to properly.
You're not gripped.
If you're.
If I can hear noise in the audience,
it's not right.
I watched one by one and I see sometimes
they're shaking their head like this.
Sometimes they're nodding.
Sometimes they look confused.
If if people look confused,
I think,
well,
I haven't got that right.
I have to be watching people and
seeing that they're understanding,
they're following along
and that indication that
they're following along helps
me figure out if I'm in the right place,
and so there's a dynamic that goes
along with it and so all of that,
and that's what you're doing if
you engage the audience properly,
is you shouldn't be talking about things
you don't know enough about to talk
about.
So if you have to read your notes,
it's like,
sorry,
you don't know enough to talk
about that because you need notes.
Now.
Maybe when you're first starting
to talk about something,
you need notes,
but if you need notes,
you haven't prepared enough.
You should know like 10 times
as much about the topic.
Then you're going to
talk about in the talk.
Otherwise,
who the hell are you?
And so while right,
I mean you're.
You're supposed to be the authority,
so you need to know these things and
so and then knowing these things,
you want to stretch them
further because when you're.
This is a theater and lecture theater.
Theater is drama,
so why is it a lecture?
Theater?
[inaudible] lecture is drama.
What's the drama?
Drama delivering a talk.
No,
there's no drama in that.
A tape recorder can do that.
The drama is to engage with the ideas
actively in real time and to discover with
the audience what the consequences
and that's what makes a novel great.
For example,
the reason that Dostoyevsky novel is
great is because Dostoevsky did not know
where he was going when he started.
He had problems,
you know,
like crime and punishment
is a great example.
He wanted to explore the relationship
between crime and punishment.
He didn't think,
well,
I'm a postmodern,
neo marxists tonight.
I have a solution to the problem of crime
and punishment and I'm going to write
a novel describing what
the right solution is.
He thought,
here's a problem,
man.
This is a major problem.
I'm going to divide myself into 10
characters and I'm going to have a war and
I'm going to see what prevails,
and he takes you along
on that voyage and it's.
That's what makes Dostoevsky
different than Ayn rand.
For example,
because Ayn rand already knew who the
good guys and the bad guys were and maybe
she was right and maybe she wasn't.
Doesn't matter what matters is that
what she did wasn't literature.
It was just sophisticated propaganda,
you know,
like it,
it taps into literature upon occasion,
but,
but she knew where she was going.
Whereas Dusky Dostoevsky,
he discovered it along the way and so
he takes you along on the journey and
that's any great artists does that
takes you along in the journey.
That's why it's so rare vivifying to
encounter anything that's genuinely
artistic is because you're along for
the conflict between chaos and order and
that's way more interesting than
having a talk delivered to you.
Is it possible that that
journey might lead to a bad.
In some cases you've spoken of Hitler
when he was speaking to audiences and he
was listening to the audiences and
that and he started to find what really
engaged them and made them,
um,
yeah,
excited.
He was saying,
is it possible that you might get
it wrong because of that dynamic?
Oh,
definitely.
And it's a terrible threat to
get it wrong because you know,
in,
in rule three,
make friends with the people
who want the best for you.
There are other rules that were associated
with that that I didn't write about.
Like make friends with people with own.
No.
Let's see.
Be Very careful with who.
Be Very careful about who
you share good news with.
That was one rule and another rule was
be very careful about whom you share bad
news with.
And those are sort of
hallmarks of friendship.
If you have friends,
you can tell good news too.
You know what it's like to tell good
news to someone that you shouldn't tell.
Good news too.
It's like they're not
happy about your good news.
There are bitter about it and
they'll show it in some way.
Maybe they'll trump your good
news or they won't listen.
Or they'll bring up another topic or
they're secretly angry or whatever.
You walk away from sharing the good news
thinking you should have kept your damn
mouth shut and that's not a good sign.
And then.
But some people you can tell good news
too and they'll be happy because they
have enough sense to know
that life's to catastrophe.
And if something good happened to you,
then hooray.
You know,
because and then bad
news is the same thing.
It's like if you tell bad news to someone,
they need to let you suffer,
right?
They shouldn't make you feel better quick
because they're upset because you're
upset,
none of that.
They just have to take it.
And that's hard.
So the,
I think I forgot what the
hell the question was here.
I'm getting tired so I'm
losing my ability to go back
where you may get it wrong when
you're interacting with the audience.
Yes.
Look
what Hitler did was
this far as I can tell,
and I've talked to politicians who've,
who've built grassroots political
parties about how they did it too.
So
the audience talks to you when you,
when you deliver,
when you,
when you speak publicly and they talk
to you with their emotional reactions,
and then you can learn how to say what
produces a given emotional reaction,
especially if that's what you want.
If you want,
say,
control over the crowd or maybe you want,
you want to harness
the anger of the crowd.
Let's say [inaudible]
your own motivations.
What were Hitler's motivations?
Here's the psychoanalytic answer.
If you cannot understand the motivations,
look at the consequences
and infer the motivation.
What's the consequence?
Hitler blows his brains out in a bunker
under Berlin when Europe is on fire.
What was the motivation
as suicidal apocalypse?
That's the motivation.
How do you generate as
suicidal apocalypse?
You a mad it.
How do you get the crowd to go along?
You speak in that manner and you watch
for the emotional response and when you
get the anger that you're after,
you facilitate it and you let your
imagination dwell on that and you become a
master of that and that's what Hitler did
and it wasn't like the Germans weren't
angry and they had their reasons.
World War One was brutal.
They lost the Versailles treaty was
a catastrophe in the 19 twenties.
Every decent hardworking German lost all
of their savings in hyperinflation and
the entire country was threatened
by a radical leftist revolution.
It was rough and people were not happy
and many of them had been terribly
brutalized by world war one,
so there was no shortage of anger to
capitalize on and Hitler was just the guy
annoyed as he was,
for example,
that he was rejected from art school
three times despite despite having a fair
bit of artistic talent.
He had his reasons for resentment and
anger and hatred and that's just a tiny
part of it.
Yes.
These things can go terribly wrong.
It depends,
at least in part on what you're aiming at.
People ask me what I'm
aiming at and I would say,
I mean who knows,
right?
Because you don't know yourself and I
don't know myself not to the final depths,
but I think what I'm aiming at,
I'm hoping is exactly
what I say I'm aiming at.
I hope that what I'm aiming
at is to tell people stories
and provide them with
clinical intervention in
information that's derived from
the best literature and science that I
know so that they can be fortified in
their ability to contend with tragedy
and malevolence and the reason that I'm
doing that.
As far as I'm concerned is because
when I wrote my first book,
which was maps of meaning,
the audio version of
which is out next week,
by the way,
I think it'll be easier to understand
because it's red and the intonation is all
there.
I concluded after studying the
psychological dynamics of the Cold War,
that the only proper medication
to tyrannical collectivism
was the sovereignty
of the individual and
that as a consequence,
the sovereign individual
needed to be strengthened.
That that was the path forward was
least harm and most potential good.
And I think that's what I'm doing my
evidence for that is that I've been doing
it for 30 years.
I taught courses based on that at
Harvard and at the University of Toronto
consistently.
The lectures were made into a television
program in Toronto that was popular.
The lecturers became
explosively popular online.
Everybody can see what I'm saying as
far as I can tell and apart from the hip
pieces,
which are perhaps valid criticisms,
although I don't believe so.
Um,
the overwhelming evidence as far as I
can tell is that it's having a positive
consequence.
So,
and I'm hoping,
and I have people watching
me and criticizing me,
like friends of mine in my family,
trying to make sure that this
all works and so hopefully
I'm not doing something that isn't good.
We'll see.
But yes.
Thanks.
The last,
last question,
what did you think of
the last star wars movie?
I've gone,
I don't know if I saw
the last star wars movie,
but I saw one of the last.
I've probably seen three of the last
five star wars movies I would say,
and I thought they were all the same
movie as the First Star Wars movie.
So,
um,
so I haven't,
they haven't been my cup of tea.
Let's say I'm having said that,
it's obvious that,
you know,
the superhero movies,
the star wars movies,
the star trek movies,
the fantastic success that marvel in
particular has had with their Superhero
Pantheon.
Like those are the most expensive
artifacts that people make a,
those movies.
That's something to really think about.
You know,
people put $200,000,000
into a movie like that.
It's not the most expensive thing we make,
but it's bloody well up there.
I can tell you,
and it's pretty interesting
to realize as well,
but making the special effects
for those movies which,
which is a form of artificial reality,
let's say,
is part of what's driving computational
sophistication forward because the big
processors are being used most
intensively to render reality.
And so whatever's happening in those
movies is something far more significant
than you might think.
I think it all speaks to the unquenchable
power of mythology and its proclivity
to manifest itself in a
multitude of forms and,
and,
and to be in t eternally
compelling to people.
And so generally that seems to
be a really good thing to me.
So I mean the Harry Potter series I think
is a better example than the star wars
series because I think that,
I think that the star wars series
is a bit too consciously contrived.
Whereas the Harry Potter series is
genuinely to my way of thinking anyways,
is it genuine intuitive production?
Um,
and rolling got her mythology.
She so good at that.
I just can't believe it.
It's just absolutely unbelievable.
And you think of the consequences of that.
She wrote seven books about wizards like
teenage wizards and child wizards and
magical castle threatened by giant snakes
and portrayed the battle between good
and evil on a landscape of
chaos and order and sold.
I don't know what's her empire worth in
terms of total financial consequences?
It would be.
It's in the tens of billions of dollars.
Certainly.
She got all these kids
to read 600 page books.
They produced all these movies
that were fantastically expensive.
Everybody read them and
went and watched them.
It's like,
and what do you see there?
It's dying and resurrecting
hero fights is satanic.
Figure and attains final victory
through death and resurrection.
So like,
you know,
and it wasn't contrived
that came out of the story.
And so
the mythologies seeps in no matter what.
And it's,
I think,
and this is something I learned from you,
is that it's time for us to understand it.
We can't just live by it
unconsciously anymore.
We have to understand that
as well as living by it.
And that's the task of the 21st century.
That's what it looks like to me.
So if we understand it,
then maybe we can fortify ourself
against collectivist ideology,
for example.
I'm hoping because that's a bad pathway.
So you were able to turn that question
into a very good final words somehow.
Good.
So thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank
you.